how to influence people and become a
master of persuasion discover advanced
methods to analyze people control
emotions and body language leverage
manipulation in business and
relationships written by john clark
narrated by andrea nelson and byron
armstrong
congratulations on purchasing how to
influence people
guide to master the psychology of
persuasion and thank you for doing so
the following chapters will discuss
about the power of persuasion learn how
to control your emotions read body
language to analyze people and many more
manipulation tactics you will be able to
use in business relationships and with
friends
the information found in this book will
best explore the techniques you need to
learn so you will be able to master the
psychology of persuasion
thanks again for choosing this audiobook
every effort was made to ensure it is
full of as much useful information as
possible
please
enjoy
introduction there is a belief amongst
most people that when sequences and
situations are created to change the
perception and reactions of a person it
is a negative thing
but if we were to look closely we would
observe that this is something that
manifests on a daily basis in our lives
we are constantly trying to change how
people see us and the things we do
sometimes we want them to view us in a
positive way and other times in a
negative way depending on what we want
to achieve at that moment in time
some people call this manipulation and
it is indeed so but manipulation is not
necessarily evil as most people would
lead you to believe
many believe it to be associated with
only exploitation and deception for
personal gain but fail to praise such
tactics when they are used positively in
eliminating unhealthy habits and
behaviors
to put this in perspective do you
remember the days when your parents had
to promise you gifts and extra play time
just to get you to complete your
homework
that is manipulation in its simplest
form
but it doesn't match up with what people
like to believe of manipulation they
clearly were not manipulating you for
reasoning for their own benefit if
anything it was for yours
people turn to manipulation for a
variety of reasons to advance their own
purposes and agendas to help you attain
your own goals and objectives to gain
power
or are already causing until they are
too far gone in the game
some people keep manipulating everyone
every time without the slightest hint of
guilt
such people
are psychopaths
this audiobook has not been produced to
turn anyone into a psychopath
nor is it written to challenge the
status quo of manipulation in the world
it is written to show you the ropes at a
skill many already utilize
yes everyday people manipulate others in
their business environments in social
settings in friendships and
relationships
so it is high time you sat down and
learnt the tricks to an art that all
influential people possess
chapter one
manipulation as a tool of masters
in the world nowadays a variety of
situations necessitates or determines
ascribing someone the title of master
but in all of those situations the
master is the one who has most influence
on the people around him or her
the power such a master possesses could
have initially been attained by skill or
reputation but to avoid losing it over
time the master has to be adept at
retaining his or her influence
such a person is usually held in high
regard regardless of status or wealth
and very rarely do these people attain
such a status by being themselves or by
being ordinary
being so might make people to like and
admire you but the true respect and
power over others must be gotten by
other means
this is where manipulation comes in
manipulation goes hand in hand with
power
wherever you can sense the effect of
manipulation there is bound to be an
imbalance of power
the power in such societies is usually
concentrated in the hands of a few who
could be referred to as masters over
others
these people are well versed at making
people think along the same lines as
them making people act along the same
lines as them
making people follow them
unconditionally
and generally being able to influence
the thoughts and opinions of those
around them effectively
if you were to look back in history at
some of the most influential people one
of the things you would observe is that
the ideas they advocated were not
necessarily moral or even right at all
their beliefs were not necessarily
righteous or ethical but whenever they
needed it people and followers flocked
to their sides ready to follow them to
the end and ready to defend the ideas
they had been taught to believe and
defend
from terrorist leaders to controversial
politicians and men of power who
regardless of the revulsion their ideas
seemed to generate still
seemed to be gaining more power
why was this so
because they knew how to influence and
control people
it didn't matter what they said but
provided they could make people think
how they wanted them to and act how they
wanted them to they were never at risk
of being powerless
their power didn't originate from a
sense of righteousness or correctness
but from the sense of followership they
were able to instill in people
it is this sense of followership and
loyalty that you should aim high to
achieve through manipulation
manipulation is not just your key to
power it is your key to success because
with power comes the ability to thrive
off people in any environment
this ability is inherent in all
successful people
whether you are an entrepreneur or
someone with a daily job as long as
people are involved
the knowledge of people and how to
influence them is necessary for your
success
some people have those
once-in-a-lifetime ideas or a
revolutionary approach to solving a
problem but without the knowledge of how
to thrive on the backs of others they
would never be able to fully consolidate
on what they have
the ability to manipulate people is
yours to use as you wish
you could use it in your search for
personal happiness or in your quest for
wealth and affluence whichever one is
your choice
this book however has only one aim
helping you become a master in whatever
you choose to be or do
the secrets of the greatest men
manipulation and deception are one of
the numerous skills possessed by the
greatest and most powerful men to have
roamed this earth
not all men are gandhi and if the
history books were properly scoured and
its annals scrutinized many of the men
who have exerted the most influence on
the world would be shown to be
manipulators who merely hid their more
negatively perceived talents in a shroud
of piety idealism and oratory
this is not to say that these men were
evil or bad
they just understood the need to do what
was necessary when necessary and if this
involved tweaking the emotions and
thoughts of people to generate reactions
that were favorable to their causes
so be it
and so the truth behind many of the
world's greatest men and leaders is not
divine intervention or an alignment of
the stars but rather a lack of the
emotional restrictions that plagued the
ordinary men
many of these men from caesar to
napoleon weren't evil or psychopathic
but had a goal and a vision of the world
that couldn't be achieved by simply
following the rules and hoping that
other persons saw things the same way
they did
no
great men do not wait
they act
not to limit this to only men
we have had some pretty powerful women
in the past who understood that to wield
real power was not a matter of honesty
or being a good wife
but rather how to get people to do what
you want when you want it
that is the essence of manipulation to
get people so dependent and so in awe of
you that you could easily influence
their principles and guide their actions
in the direction you believe it ought to
be going in
take for instance the sexual
manipulation of both caesar and mark
anthony by cleopatra in a bid to protect
her interests and titles
it is mostly overlooked but that has in
no way detracted from her brilliant
manipulation of two very powerful men
what i am trying to say here is that
many of the events that have shaped the
world politically industrially even
religiously are so mired in manipulation
it's hard to dismiss its usefulness in
both the old days and the modern world
it is used as a business tactic as a
means of motivation or as an aid to
persuasion in almost any facet of life
in the modern world
manipulation is synonymous with politics
and is widely thought to be used only by
politicians business executives and the
like but if you look closely you would
see that we all practice a form of
manipulation
in fact any setting in which there seems
to be an imbalance of power
probably contains an element of
manipulation and
since this imbalance in power is a
staple of the realistic world
it could be said that manipulation is
rife in the world and in our everyday
life
there is manipulation in our daily
interactions in our personal
relationships our business relationships
and even religious interactions
consider the clergy who spends a large
chunk of his sermon emphasizing on
punishment of sin and the travails of
hell
he might be speaking the truth but his
words are meant to impart fear in you
and it is that fear which he counts on
to make the difference in your approach
to life
that is a classic case of emotional
manipulation
using fear
the cleric does not mean to do this but
deep down he realizes that this is the
most effective way of knocking into
people the need for his or her god he
does not mean to manipulate you but he
does it nonetheless
that is what manipulation is
you might truly respect the autonomy of
a person when you feel you need to
influence them you could unknowingly
find yourself trying to take advantage
of their emotions and this means you are
manipulating them
you do not have to be evil you simply
need to recognize the necessity for a
line of action and possess the strength
of mind to do what needs to be done
over the course of this audio book you
would learn how to wield similar power
over people how to make yourself
indispensable and how to make yourself
capable of greatness
the often overlooked human need to be
manipulated
as humans we have all been blessed with
autonomy the right to make our own
decisions and live by them and any
threat to such autonomy generally has us
on guard
that is the reason why when faced with
anything law or person we believe aims
to rip this independence from us
we fight back with or without violence
take into consideration the numerous
uprisings in history as proof of this
the people who led the french and
english revolutions did not possess more
power than the monarchs in power but
when they felt their needs being thrown
out the door and their independence
being preyed upon
they fought back
and they fought hard
our history when it comes to defending
our independence is quite rich from the
early advocates of our modern religious
facing up to the idol worshippers in
their day to the women throughout
history who have fought for equal rights
they might have not realized what they
were doing but they were exercising an
innate human need to be free
but just as the need to be free exists
so does the need to be controlled or the
need for order
this need to be controlled is the reason
why humans needed monarchs and
governments to rule and govern their
daily life
because if left to live life freely and
unchecked we would have been consumed by
chaos
but as our population grew and we
expanded to cover more territory
so did the influence of such monarchs
and governments the controlling forces
on our life where thin
even becoming insignificant
though this is on a much grander scale
and might
it is a larger manifestation of our need
to sometimes be guided by others
thus it is apt to say that every one of
us needs
guidance
the guidance might be spiritual academic
or psychological but if we were to trace
the source of our knowledge we would
find that it must have originated from a
person or book and very rarely is it
completely original
to better understand this consider how
you always feel the need to try and
impart the knowledge you have unto
others either by holding lectures or by
giving advice
this need to guide one another is how we
humans have passed on our knowledge over
millenniums it is because of this
inherent need for guidance knowledge and
control that we are susceptible to
manipulation
i'm not saying that anybody deserves to
be manipulated but that everybody can be
manipulated
and since whatever is possible is always
done
the possibility of being manipulated
means that some of us or rather many of
us are bound to fall victim to people
whose goal is to manipulate us
it is the way of the world
the only difference between you and the
next person is how good you are at it
and how you want to use your influence
and skill
manipulation is not evil
it's
just a tool
it is widely believed that manipulation
is evil
i neither support nor assert to this
belief manipulation is the use of any
sort of influence be it physical
emotional or financial over a person
group or situation to generate a desired
outcome
the outcome is most likely one which
favors you and your goals but does not
necessarily need to be detrimental to
the other people involved
on another note the belief of
manipulation being negative usually
assumes that this goal you want to
achieve is not in sync with that of your
mark or target
but
what if it does
won't it then be more apt to classify
your manipulation as a means of
motivation or at the very least as a
positive influence
consider this
you have a boss who is hell-bent on
following a particular line of action as
regards a new business deal
yet facts and your gut tell you that his
approach or decision is a wrong one
but he refuses to listen to the opinions
of anyone probably because his stance is
a result of a very old sentiment or bias
in this case every straightforward and
honest approach has failed
wouldn't it be better to manipulate and
tweak his emotions just a little bit
and save his job and the company's
balance sheet from recording a loss
in such a case your manipulation of your
boss is still considered immoral but on
the general balance of events it is the
right course of action if all means of
rational persuasion have been exhausted
from a conventional point of view the
idea of one person manipulating another
is considered a criticism of the
manipulator's
behavior but
is manipulation always immoral
the above example doesn't seem immoral
when looked at on a grander scale we
would most likely agree that
manipulation is rife in our everyday
life but the only times it is actually
classified as evil or bad is when it
leads to harm be it emotional or
psychology of the target
sure manipulation can expose
vulnerabilities that otherwise might
have remained hidden
yes manipulation could lead to
oppression of people
but it could also be the only way to
achieve a truly noble goal consider this
next example
assuming you are a security officer who
was unlucky enough to be on duty on the
day a terrorist was captured and you
have credible intel that the terrorist
is slated to carry out an attack on that
very day or maybe during the week you
have tried every possible method of
rational reasoning from trying to tap
into his or her empathy to offering
deals but the terrorist has refused to
budge and the only way to extract the
information without resorting to
violence is to employ manipulation as a
tool
is this considered immoral or is the
immorality simply justified simply
because
you get to save many lives
depending on your answer to the above
question the knowledge shared in this
book might one day be beneficial to you
if you possess a hard-line view on the
perception of manipulation and are of
the opinion that it can never be used
for a positive goal
the knowledge of this book is of no
practical use to you
and you're better served stopping here
and picking a book that is more
acceptable and is less likely to offend
your sensibilities
chapter 2
mastering your emotions and reactions
manipulation is a game of emotions
knowing how to read them how to tweak
them how to play them erase them create
them
and react to them
every manipulative move should be aimed
at exposing the emotional core of your
mark or target because that is the only
way of owning their actions and
decisions
but for you to adequately and
efficiently affect your desired change
in the individual or group of relevance
you have to have an understanding of
yourself and your emotions
to put it cleanly you have to know
yourself more than any other person
because only then can you make a move at
controlling others
know yourself
this is key
knowing yourself is key if not the most
important ingredient to possess before
you embark on the road to mastering
people
this is because to avoid overreaching or
underestimating yourself you have to
possess an understanding of your
abilities a keen sense as to where your
strengths end and where your weaknesses
begin
only with this knowledge can you
decipher the direction in which you
should be leading your mark and the
approach you should be taking to do so
such in-depth knowledge of oneself would
require a level of truthfulness in
accepting one's limitations and a
further level of self-discipline to
avoid crossing those limits
the idea behind getting under your
target's defenses would vary depending
on the target but would require you to
either play up your weaknesses while
emphasizing your strengths or play up
your strengths while emphasizing your
weaknesses both require you to be alert
as important as understanding your
limits it would be nothing without an
understanding of your emotions and that
would be incomplete without the ability
to recognize your emotional markers
these markers are what people see
regardless of what goes on in your head
and thus are more likely to influence
their thoughts
this knowledge is not achieved by simply
making a resolution but by logically
analyzing your every move in a bid to
pinpoint how your internal emotions
manifest as external actions
this might seem complex but it is
actually quite easy
it just involves thinking about your
reactions and emotion as two separate
entities
then
following them through step by step to
the end and figuring out how one
influences the other
let me give you a hypothetical situation
a friend of yours who is usually quiet
and reserved walks up to you one day and
she shoves you in the back in a moment
of excitement
it was a playful shove
but you not realizing it with this
particular friend turns back and are
about to express your anger
before you notice him and check yourself
he sees this and wonders why you would
react in such a way and in a playful
manner shoves you again
this time however you don't check
yourself but instead launch into a
tirade
at the time he hit you the first time
let's assume you were in a rather normal
state not particularly angry or happy
after the first hit you got angry but
controlled yourself
while this control is necessary to
possess for the skill you're learning
the important part of your analysis
should be
what gave your anger away
since you had not actually reacted
you have to know if it was a clenched
fist by your side a hardened facial
expression a twitching eye or whatever
because controlling the reaction is only
half the lesson
you have to behave outwardly like the
thought of a reaction never even crossed
your mind
this is the kind of logical breakdown
you must grow adept at performing on
yourself and your actions
you must abandon the ordinary man's
habits of reacting impulsively and start
reacting logically
next you have to consider your loss of
control on the succeeding incident
such a reaction could point to the shove
itself being an act that ticks you off
an underlying problem or problems with
the aforementioned friend or even your
limit in such situations
whichever one it is
you need to get a handle on it and
eliminate all emotions from your
reactions unless when you feel it has to
be released
be the master of your emotions
other than your strengths and weaknesses
another key area of your life and being
to pay attention to is your emotions
most people underestimate the need for a
control over their emotions and that is
the major reason they have little
control over the emotions of others
i am not advising for you to remain meek
regardless of the provocation or for you
to flare up at the slightest sign of
resistance no
what i am saying is that you have to be
able to control whatever reaction is
necessary in the moment
to bring it out at a moment's notice and
to lock it back up when it has served
its purpose
you need to recognize your emotional
triggers and work at dulling their
effect
failing at such an important facet of
your person could lead you to
unwillingly push a target too far
or to allow a target to run wild and
free for too long
meanwhile mastering the control of your
emotion in this way would give the
double advantage of reducing the ability
people possess to rile you up or
manipulate you
while also granting you complete
autonomy over your own reactions
as i implied earlier different targets
required different approaches and
different treatments and for this reason
different emotions would elicit
different effects on them
where anger might cause one to be
subservient it might cause another to be
more belligerent
this is the major reason you have to
master not just the ability to act and
create emotional reactions but also the
ability to suppress your more natural
emotional reactions as these said
reactions can interfere with the image
you are trying to portray
your control on your emotions is one of
the major tools by which you control the
perception people have of you and when
it comes to manipulating people it is
key that you control their perception of
you because only then would you control
how they will treat you
it is important for you to remember that
the initial way by which people judge
another's character is through his or
her behavior and emotional disposition
and as such control over both would
grant unto you the power to controls
people perception of you
from another angle
your emotional disposition towards
issues and events is usually a
cornerstone of your reputation at least
in the minds of most people this is a
weakness in people they assume that
emotions are almost unchangeable thereby
nullifying the possibility in their
minds that one is capable of
manipulating his or her emotions to
deceive them
they believe that your reaction to a
situation would always stay consistent
unless another effect is in play
the trick is
introducing another reaction or emotion
that contradicts your normal in a bid to
gain their attention
while
lowering their defenses to deal with
your perceived soft spot
because of this nullification this is a
belief you must always be out to take
advantage of
the warning behind this is that before
attempting to cash in on this mistake
you have to have fine-tuned your ability
to act out scenarios and create emotions
if you are not well versed at this
a smart target might figure out your
play before you're even started
furthermore when utilizing this weakness
the emotion being introduced should be
as evanescent as possible so as not to
confuse the target
what i mean is that with such a tactic
the effect you're going for is the
oh that is so unlike him
effect and not the
oh
he has changed so much from the time we
met
effect
this means that the emotion to be
introduced should be temporary and
fleeting only surfacing for a brief
period of time
most times the tactic is effective for a
particular emotion only once or twice
and should never be attempted
consecutively using the same emotion
here is an illustration of this
particular trick
the target is a female and you have gone
through the basics with her establishing
a character and manufacturing reactions
for every predictable action of hers
in your bid to seduce her
you have gotten to first base first kiss
and now you're looking to score a big
finish and leave
but she's been very coy and defensive
about sex and you haven't been able to
lower her defenses on the issue
one day an issue comes up between you
guys and ordinarily you would have let
it slide with a smile
but instead you flare up for a bit and
take to keeping to yourself
she avoids bringing up the issue for a
while but later comes in for the
conversation
the major point here is the change from
your regular emotional reaction to a
more aggressive one
this would prompt her to believe that
you might have lost a little bit of
emotional control and seeing as such
instability is a constant source of
discussion in relationships
your current countenance would require
her to have a conversation with you
bear in mind that the conversation is
not for you to petulantly complain about
her for not having sex with you but
rather for you to make her feel she is
in a position of power to broker peace
while considering you to be the victim
you are not making things overly hard or
easy for her
your time to act would come after you've
settled the quarrel
it might be right for you to initiate a
make-out session rather than to ask her
to have sex
this moment in which she has lowered her
defenses to accommodate your emotional
issues is when you make your move
and if you have played your cards right
up to that moment you are about to get
that score you have been hoping for
from then onwards it is up to you to
proceed as you wish but with smarts of
course
do not forget overusing this tactic
increases the possibility of exposing
your game to your target
develop your instincts
instincts are natural they are either
born from experience or you're born with
them it is that voice in your head that
speaks to you when you're in a fix and
need a quick solution to your problem
it is the one that guides most of your
impulsive reactions i bet you used to
doubt your impulses could change but
trust me they can
many people believe impulses can only be
controlled but that is for someone who
still wants to possess impulses
real masters of emotions do not just
control their impulses
they eliminate them
only when those impulses are absent do
the instincts you have trained yourself
in start to kick in
our instincts are a product of our
deeper nature our deeper understanding
and our environment
they usually mirror the things we have
learned and experienced
when we act on our instincts we're
basically surrendering to our past
experiences and innermost directions
these directions can be changed but not
easily
to truly develop your instincts is not a
matter of turning pages or staring at a
screen and absorbing words but rather
putting your skills to the test in real
life and facing failure because only
with these can you correct the folly of
past experiences and create new
directions
you have to put your newly learned
tactics to work
feel them out recognize how to make them
click for you and depending on what you
succeed or fail at
your mind will automatically store all
of these experiences as either positive
results inducing actions or negative
results inducing actions
it is based on the presence of this more
advanced knowledge that your instincts
become sharper and more trustworthy
because you stop making decisions
steeped in theoretical propaganda and
start making experienced decisions
instincts are necessary in understanding
people and situations because only when
you know what to look out for can you
correctly react but in instances where
the mark is still more of a stranger you
have to rely on your instincts and
experiences to guess what type of person
you're dealing with in terms of
temperament likes dislikes potential
tells and the likes
without the necessary sharp instincts
these would be quite difficult if not
impossible
chapter 3
knowledge of emotional reactions and how
to read them
reading people is arguably the most
vital tool to a successful manipulation
this might be an art to some or a
science to others depending on if they
are naturally talented at it or if it is
a completely acquired skill
don't get me wrong i do not mean to say
that some people are born with the
ability to read people what i mean is
that it comes easier to some people with
time than others
reading people and their emotions is a
historically difficult task and yet
without it attempting a manipulation is
akin to a blind man climbing a mountain
many believe it to be about making snap
decisions based on how people look and
jumping to conclusions before you have
even shared a word but in truth
it is way more than that before we jump
into this i should warn you that
psychologists have confirmed that there
is no foolproof way to read or decipher
people and i would like to personally
add that many of the methods you might
learn might seem contradictory
having said this it is up to you to
engage your wits and let your instincts
guide you
a key facet of reading people is their
emotional disposition towards various
situations to really understand them
through this means you need to have
watched them react to a few situations
so as to give you a feel as to how they
might react in similar and contrasting
settings
however
emotions are notoriously difficult to
decipher and many amateurs make the
mistake of translating signs and
gestures
into singular meanings
this is wrong because a sign could
denote multiple possible emotions
it is due to this possibility that signs
and gestures should not be treated or
read as individual entities but rather
should be taken contextually while also
putting into consideration other facts
available to you
the last ingredient that is needed to
make the result of a reading as close to
reality as possible is a sharp instinct
i have spoken about developing this in
chapter two and will refrain from
discussing further but in my opinion it
is the most important tool for reading
people knowing your mark
the first step to reading a mark or
target is to abandon all of your
previous projections and prejudices
about people
these prejudices could be
racial ethnic etc but they should all be
thrown out because without a clean slate
on which to present your facts you risk
destroying your readings with bias and
sentiments
as a manipulator your main goal in
reading people especially strangers is
not to spot deceit
but to spot openings which could be used
to forge connections or to discover
character traits that could be used to
your advantage
i would advise that when initially
attempting manipulations you pick
targets that are more insecure lonely or
are possessing of low self-esteem
this is usually obvious from their need
to defend themselves regularly and
eagerness to join or participate in a
conversation
shyness tendency to back down from
confrontations and similar behaviors
a general way to get people to initially
lower their defenses with you is to act
charming
do not act all weird and slimy with them
but adopt a natural witty charm the kind
reserved for your principal or favorite
high school teacher back in the day
this is especially effective with shy or
insecure targets people who would
welcome compliments and are more likely
to warm to jokes and strangers faster
another way is to break down the trust
barrier by offering a little of yourself
and your secrets first
this part of you doesn't necessarily
have to be true
but it must be believable
once the primary connection is formed
however it is time to begin information
gathering
if your mark is talkative you're in luck
simply keep quiet and let the prattle
run
there is bound to be at least a tidbit
of information scattered in between
however if the target is more reserved
or quieter a little bit of skillful
prodding is needed to tap into the right
vibe and once you get it be sure to keep
the buzz going for as long as possible
other than information garnered from
conversation you can also proceed to
watch the crowd he or she hangs out with
her favorite drinks favorite color and
hobbies
this might seem very banal but knowledge
of them could give you an in with the
mark and that's all that is needed to
improve your status in their lives once
you have established the right
relationship
the next step is to hunt for more
private bits of information the ones
most likely to push the buttons you need
pushed
observing and translating emotional
reactions
to properly observe a person's reactions
and understand the logic or motive
behind them
you have to take an objective
perspective of the person's actions
devoid of any connections whatsoever
to do this you first have to establish
the nature of the events or situations
causing such a reaction to check for its
conventionality
because since most people tend to react
conventionally to certain things the
abnormalities and oddities are the ones
to look out for
next you analyze the markers of these
reactions in the person so that if such
a reaction were to occur for another
stimulus it would be clear what such a
person is feeling
some emotions may possess the same
marker and would therefore require
secondary markers or experience with the
target to tell them apart
the need for marking the emotional
reaction of the target as well as its
causes is to be well placed to use the
emotions to your advantage also knowing
the tells would expose to you the
presence of a particular emotion
allowing you to adapt to the mood and
needs of the person thus keeping
yourself relevant while making them
believe that you care this might
probably only be necessary at the
beginning of the association as the
person is more likely to show more
subservience or dependence as the
manipulations grow deeper
deciphering and translating the emotions
of a person might seem tricky at first
but
usually gets easier with time
for instance staying with a new cousin
family relative or roommate might be
difficult at first but as you start to
warm up to them and learn about their
eccentricities what makes them tick and
what kills their buzz
their secrets begin to up to you one at
a time
it's the same way with targets of
manipulations you need to invest time in
understanding and learning their
reactions and what they mean so as to
avoid pushing the wrong buttons at the
wrong times
learn to take a cue
very rarely you might encounter an
oddity that more or less does not
conform to the reading you have arrived
at on a particular person
do not fret and do not react too swiftly
it is better to ignore it outwardly
while watching for signs of repetition
the smart play would be to analyze it
try to understand what brought about the
anomaly and is it likely to happen again
this is necessary because manipulation
is about control of not only the target
but of everything affecting the target
that can be controlled
those that cannot be controlled should
be predicted and skillfully avoided to
prevent any surprises from occurring
take for example you have cultivated a
manipulative relationship with a young
lady or man who is quite reserved and is
more prone to long periods of silence
then on a night out together the target
completely flips script and goes all
wild partygoer on you
do not react hastily it could be as a
result of something or someone in their
life that you're not familiar with and a
hasty reaction against a previously
entrenched stimulus could be rather
counterproductive
instead it would be advisable for you to
go along with the flow and later
question their behavior
this would enable you to gain the
knowledge you want without relinquishing
control of the situation
this is the idea behind taking a clue
you have to be ready to adapt and shift
your position to better understand a
situation
to react or to obey
the key to always getting it right
this is one of my favorite rules because
it requires patient thinking and smart
decision making
the translation is rather simple
to react is to adopt an active approach
while to obey
is to do otherwise
the rule applies to you the manipulator
and the target
it is simply used to stop impulsive
action
the question is quite straightforward do
you react to a situation or let things
slide
this question is one you should never
fail to ask yourself before putting
another ploy in motion
it would be reckless of you if you were
to move too fast and sloppy of you if
you were to move too slowly
that is where the question comes in
it challenges you to consider your
status and decide if any further action
is necessary failure to make the right
choice
often ends in regret
an alternative question mostly used at
the beginning of a manipulation to
better gauge the chances of success of
the ploy is to ask yourself
how smart your target truly is
this might seem ordinary but for you to
succeed you have to have complete faith
in your own abilities while staring
clear of overconfidence and most times a
good perception of the target's own
intellect is the perfect constraint
as effective as this rule could be there
is no trick or shortcut to knowing the
answer to the question to react or to
obey could only be answered by you
you are to put every piece of
information you possess on the target
into play and then
consult your gut and instincts on
whether one or the other is the right
choice
you would probably stumble a few times
during the learning process but you
could also be a natural getting it right
every single time
whichever it is remember to always learn
from your experiences because only
through our experiences are we ever
truly equipped to deal with the future
practice makes perfect
as previously stated manipulation has to
be worked out constantly to attain the
level at which success becomes the norm
practice and constant use of the skills
you learn would sharpen your skills as
regards people and how they should be
dealt with
all the advice in this book are merely
words on a piece of paper or an audio
recording without your own ability to
bring them to life
everyone is different and as such
different methods work for them
this applies to you as much as it
applies to your target you have to be
able to bring the ideas in this book in
a way that suits your character and
approach and there is no better way to
learn to do this than by practicing
manipulation is a game that deals with
emotions and constant practice is
perfect to boost your instincts as well
as your confidence stick to these rules
and warning and it's only a matter of
time before you become a master
manipulator
just like in every other field without
sharp instincts you are ordinary without
experience you carry a large chance of
failure
without confidence you can do nothing
practice is important if you are to
achieve all three and rise above being
ordinary
chapter 4
understanding basic body language
when two people meet each other it
doesn't matter whether they're old
friends or new acquaintances they could
even be strangers
but they communicate through not only
words but gestures
these gestures tend to betray our mental
state and express how we are feeling for
instance if we were feeling bad and
irritable we give off defensive signals
and when we are feeling happy we tend to
be more relaxed and friendlier
these gestures and signals relay our
mood to the person or persons around us
and affects what they think and how they
relate with us at that moment in time
this ability to read basic and common
gestures is rather inherent in everyone
but as a result of practice and
experience some people are more adept at
it than others for example
women are generally more perceptive to
gestures than men probably due to the
fact that they might have had lots of
practice dealing with their kids or
those of others
many common gestures such as crying
laughing and frowning denote the same
emotional and mental state in most
people with very little exceptions
however your emphasis on body language
and gestures as a manipulator
should go beyond the study of the more
common gestures if you hope to become a
master
it should at least encompass the
knowledge of basic body language for you
to truly appreciate its effect on your
everyday choices and decisions
you should also be able to notice and
translate a wide range of uncommon
expressions
gestures and signals could mean many
things in different places so it would
be wise to observe the general trends
around wherever you stay and ask
questions when necessary before jumping
to needless conclusions
furthermore the frequencies with which
these gestures occur vary with a variety
of factors
one of these is age
it has been proven that the older people
get the lesser the gestures they use in
communicating their opinions
another factor is wealth or social class
it has also been noted that people
higher up in the social chain in a
particular environment use fewer
gestures than those below them these are
all generalizations and exceptions to
such are bound to occur
for example people who are very excited
tend to gesticulate more and those who
are bored take on a more reserved
demeanor thus a bored teenager could
probably use less gestures and body
movement in expressing him or herself
than an excited septugenarian
in such a case the age generalization
would have failed
well other than these generalizations it
is important to pay attention to the
particular gestures of each person while
also monitoring their verbal output
look for contradictions that give the
person away is regard whether they are
lying or hiding something and make your
next steps based on these deductions
the most effective way of catching lying
in a person is to watch out for gestures
that betray their true intention
such gestures or behaviors are usually
out of place or out of sync with the
message they're delivering or trying to
deliver
understanding from less than words
the ability to tell as much as possible
about a person without engaging in
conversations is one that would help you
well especially when it comes to
securing and developing a new target
when i say developing a target i mean
the first few conversations and meetings
you have in which you try to determine
the attitude and emotional disposition
of the person towards key issues so as
to better mold the character you would
assume around them
this understanding of a person could aid
your quest in many ways it could portray
you as someone who is perceptive and
sensitive to their needs and this is a
good way of establishing trust within
the target
it could also be useful in predicting
the actions of a person as to better
react to them
this reaction could be in many forms
varying from a modified approach to a
subject to a complete avoidance of
another
it is in summary a good way to avoid
falling a foul of a person before you
have been able to achieve what you
initially set out to achieve
many signs could actually mean more than
one thing and should not be taken as a
complete truth but rather as a possible
truth
what this means is that all possible
translations should be considered before
you jump to any final conclusions
this is due to the fact that more than
one factor could be in play and probably
the telling factor causing a particular
reaction is not even from us but from
another person or situation entirely
such considerations should apply to both
positive and negative reactions because
we as humans tend to apply this to only
the negatives while imagining all
positive reactions to be of our own
making
i'm going to consider the reactions we
should or could expect in a first
meeting because i assume that after the
first meeting your status or likely
status should be established already
let us begin with reactions to expect in
a first meeting
one
acceptance and rejection
being able to perceive whether someone
is digging you or accepting your
approach is quite important as it tells
you a lot about the success of your
current approach on the person and
whether or not you may need to change it
though it is very difficult to know if
your message is getting through
little gestures such as moving closer
and interrupting every now and then to
put in a point should bolster your
confidence that your presence is at
least not unwanted
in fact if you really want to judge
whether or not your company is pleasing
to the person it would be more apt to
look for the signals of rejection
rather than those of acceptance
you should look for signs such as how
regularly the person offers an opinion
during a conversation
how frequently and how sincerely the
person smiles or laughs at your jokes
whether the person retreats whenever you
move closer and how long the person
spends in a side conversation with
another friend before returning to you
and whether or not they apologize
the regularity with which the person
offers opinions show how much the person
is concentrating on your words and this
in turn denotes if and how interesting
your company is
if the person speaks only a little it
could mean that the person doesn't like
you or is bored
anyhow if walking away
is not an option you could resort to
asking a question and using the person's
answer to change the topic
watch for changes in their reactions to
gauge their concentration
someone who laughs frequently and
sincerely at your jokes is definitely
enjoying the conversation and is less
likely to leave soon
however someone who just stares at you
after a joke or gives a weak smile is
probably not impressed by you or your
wit
but before jumping to conclusions the
blank stare could also be as a result of
a lack of understanding on their part
if after a few minutes of a conversation
you attempt to lean in to emphasize a
point and the target mostly females in
this case
retreats taking a step or two back
it could mean that she doesn't like you
or still considers you a stranger she is
surprised or she simply isn't feeling
the conversation as much as you thought
it might even be due to
mouth odor the trick with dealing with
this is to stay calm and pretend not to
notice this
continue with the conversation as
naturally as possible and after a few
minutes attempt to lean in again
if she retreats again it is probably due
to one of the first two possible reasons
or the mouth odor
during conversations with a person it is
quite common for side conversations with
a passing friend to occur the duration
of this side conversation could however
be of significance when it comes to
determining how they view you
if the side conversation goes on for so
long that you look and feel like you're
standing all alone
and yet the person with whom you were
conversing hasn't offered an apology
the meaning is quite bad
but if the person constantly cuts short
the side conversation to apologize to
you and even takes the hard decision of
cutting short and postponing such a
conversation it means your presence is
at least appreciated and not unwanted
if the former was actually the case it
could be due to the fact that the target
considers your presence to be boring and
the side conversation to be a needed
reprieve
if this is so
walk away and do not return
unless the target approaches you
save your dignity
2. happiness
someone who immediately warms up to you
in a first meeting or conversation and
is happy to have your company would most
likely participate in the conversation
not just butting in to express opinions
but also to tell stories and crack jokes
such a person is also likely to laugh a
lot and may even attempt to introduce
you to a few more people if you are a
stranger at whatever place you're
meeting
it is also possible that the person is
intoxicated
and their overly positive reaction is
due to whatever intoxicant they might
have ingested
the best way to deal with this is to go
on with the flow and probably try
getting their contact information for a
future meeting but keeping whatever
conclusions you may have had aside for
when such a meeting comes
a distant possibility is that they are
utilizing your company to achieve a goal
of their own say
making someone jealous
i classified this as a distant
possibility because it rarely happens
but i still felt the need to mention it
so as to stress the need for you to
always consider
all options and to always stay aware of
everything going on around you and your
target
three
distaste or dislike
this is different from rejection in that
the person in this case would probably
not even be polite enough to answer you
properly
it is rather easy to spot and could
include signs like a frown
lack of eye contact and short or
monosyllabic answers
if this happens to you
do not inquire as to what might be wrong
or what you might have done wrong
instead
say your goodbyes and walk away
if you're to approach such a person
again be sure to have a friend of theirs
to introduce you first this could make
all the difference
the possible scenarios are endless but
these are the most popular reactions you
could come up against the reason for
outlining these situations and how to
deal with them is to enable you to use
the knowledge of basic body language and
how to properly react to them to better
make a first conversation or meeting as
fruitful as possible
if dealing with failure and rejection is
not a strong point of yours it might be
better to watch from a distance how such
a person relates with others and judge
using these same skills how to approach
such a person or if he or she is
worth the stress
the little things are usually most
important
we have touched on some of the more
elaborate and obvious gestures and the
little ones are up next
these are called little because they are
mostly imperceptible and are done very
quickly
they are those things one is likely to
miss or overlook such as a quick lick of
the lip a glance at a wristwatch or
clock
a glance at another person or even
running a hand through their hair
these things are likely to possess
meanings that are particular to
different people and as such the same
meaning might not apply to different
people
these types of reactions should not be
studied and translated as individual
events or reaction but instead as a part
of a larger one to adequately guess the
meaning to this sort of reactions you
need to consider other gestures that
might have come immediately before it
what the target was saying at the moment
of the reaction and any possible
contradictions between the two
the truth is such reactions rarely occur
only once
most times they are conditioned reflexes
in the person to help them deal with
something they are otherwise
uncomfortable with
it is equally as rare for anyone to
recognize any of these reactions not to
talk of translating it without spending
a tremendous amount of time with the
person
for this reason such reactions are
psychological gold and should be
cherished
these inherent reactions are what we
call
tells recognizing tells and signs could
be an art or science
the ability to instantly recognize a
tell or sign in a person when you see
one could be an inborn or a developed
attribute one could simply spend a few
weeks with people and be able to reveal
three or four tells that point to how
the target is really feeling while
others spend years and still struggle to
recognize one
this is no reason to worry because while
the ability to notice and translate
tells makes manipulation easier the
absence of such a skill doesn't make it
impossible
having said this it should be noted that
recognizing such tells can be learned so
if you lack the natural knack for seeing
them you can still manipulate your
target but knowing how to recognize some
would definitely be advantageous
some tells could be the tendency for a
person to run his or her hands through
the hair
crossing of the fingers rapid blinking
twitching of the eye
wrapping the knuckles on a surface and
many others
these seem like actions that denote
rather obvious emotions but most tells
are the major issue with a tell is that
these obvious actions do not actually
follow an easily perceivable emotion and
are usually done so quickly they could
be mistaken for necessary thus
to notice them one must be observant and
to translate them you might have a good
grasp of whatever situation them might
have occurred under
isolating the situation and breaking it
down into a list of potential stimuli
could help in narrowing down the
possible meanings
recognizing a target
one of the most important things for
being a good manipulator is the ability
to notice the right people the ability
to pick the right targets
well
sorry
there are no right targets
the truth is that
everyone can be manipulated by a master
but it takes a lot of practice to become
a master and as such for beginners like
you
picking the easy or more susceptible
targets is the smarter move
generally speaking the easiest people to
manipulate are usually those with low
self-esteem low confidence or other form
of insecurities
these traits usually manifest in
numerous forms and it is these forms you
have to be trained to notice
naivete
this is a very popular draw for
manipulation because the victim is
almost never aware that he or she
possesses such a trait and this limits
the possibility that they will
eventually discover you
it could be noticed clearly in people
who always strive to see the best in
others
such a person even when confronted with
the idea and even evidence of
manipulation
is likely to still believe everything is
a coincidence and should have another
explanation
this is definitely one you should look
out for
emotional dependence
people who exhibit this trait are almost
always in relationships and such
relationships are almost always ending
why is this
because their happiness depends on the
happiness of others and due to this they
could be considered
needy
but their neediness is to your advantage
these sorts of people would do anything
to keep you happy even if it goes
against their best interests and the
best thing is they do it quite willingly
this would mean little effort from you
and an almost servile target
the only caveat to this type of person
is that they are mostly always the
jealous types
be careful
low self-confidence
if you have ever met someone with low
self-confidence you'd agree with me that
they are always seeking validations of
their actions and decisions and these
tend to expose them to manipulation
as a manipulator your power over this
class of people lies in your approval
and the way you use it
withholding such an approval makes them
eager to please and giving them the
approval makes them happy relaxed
and ripe for the taking
pseudo-manipulators
have you ever met people who like to
feel like they are the smartest and most
powerful in the room
if yes
this is their class
people like this usually feel like they
can prey on others and are good
manipulators but in truth are nothing
but failures
they are very hard to find but if you
ever meet such a person who acts out
manipulative tendencies but possesses no
real influence on people
you have your mark
the way to handle such people is to play
the victim or subordinate and strive to
avoid doing their wishes while making
sure they do yours
this might involve a whole lot of acting
and a few concessions at the beginning
but would definitely be worth the hassle
at the end
these people are mostly narcissists and
are easy to pick out using this very
trait
lack of assertiveness these kinds of
people do not have the ability to make
up their mind and this is a weakness to
take advantage of
you should strive to play the role of
bully or higher authority someone who
makes decisions for them
provided you play up your best decisions
while hiding your worst you're bound to
stay in their lives and stay in control
altruism
this is one of those traits that are
present in people who show a high level
of honesty fairness and empathy emphasis
on the empathy
this is the emotion to go after as it
blinds the target to your true nature
and makes him more likely to buy into
your act
this makes he or she susceptible to your
talents but not foolish so you'd still
have to play your cards right to have
the desired impact
there are many other traits to look out
for and with time and experience you'd
discover them looking closely you would
notice that at least one of these traits
is present in everyone you know
this is the reason why everyone even
yourself can be manipulated and as such
while playing your game
never drop your guard
and always be on the lookout in case
your target is also playing a game on
you i should also add that while these
traits make people more susceptible to
manipulation
your abilities and skills are the
factors that would truly determine if
the manipulation would be successful or
not warning signs
everybody can be manipulated but some
people are less likely to fall than
others
if you are a beginner and you're just
learning the ropes it is necessary for
you to avoid individuals high up on the
less likely list
to achieve this you need to know the
particular traits or character types to
look out for
such people are
the stubborn they are not impossible to
break but are better avoided because
they might cost too much effort
stubborn people are usually hard to
manipulate because they have
self-created opinions whose tenants they
uphold strictly
worse is the fact that they are prone to
arguing a lot and seeing as this is
rather inherent in them it is a trait
you would have to figure a way around if
you plan on sticking around
except
you are very confident you can get the
job done
steer clear
insensitive people
this type lacks the ability to feel much
in terms of empathy or sympathy that
only cares about their own interests you
might think that's a good thing but
remember
their well-being is most likely top of
their worries and any sign of
manipulation is sure to set off alarm
bells
immature people
immaturity is normally a trait that
should set people out for manipulation
because it is a close sibling of naivety
however most immature people possess the
ability to hold grudges for a tremendous
period of time
and you do not want them hunting you
down for hurting their feelings or
stealing their properties they tend to
make very determined enemies
the stubborn also possess this tendency
people with close friends and relatives
the best targets are usually those who
reside far away from most family and
friends because this reduces the chance
of trusted outside forces trying to undo
your work
unless you can think of a way to wean
your target off such influence or at
least
factor them into your plans the ploy is
going to be extremely difficult to pull
off even if you are ready to manipulate
the entire group
ask yourself
is it worth the effort
chapter 5
persuasion the psychological theories
never fail to consider the target
persuasion is a deliberate effort to
change or alter a person's opinions
beliefs or attitude towards a particular
issue situation object or person
this is usually achieved by transmission
of a message which could be verbal or
symbolic
while persuasion could be used in a
manipulative sense it is in actual sense
different from
manipulation this is because when
persuading a person he or she is usually
aware of your efforts at changing their
point of view and willingly or
reluctantly allows you to try
in this instance the person listens and
concentrates on what you're saying and
then tries to rationalize your ideas
with reality before then putting
whatever conclusions they come to
comparison with what they previously
believed
your role in the entire dynamic is to
state your reasons for the change you're
prescribing
give illustrations and evidence
supporting your views and try to
convince the target of your advances
that your line of action or advice
is their best bet
the main goal of this is getting them to
switch to a state of reasoning or a
product that you prefer
it is in this that persuasion resembles
manipulation because your goal is still
to push the target towards an outcome
that they might ordinarily not have
considered right
the success attained in persuasion
usually depends on the preconceptions
held by the target and their strength
their perception of the person sharing
the new message or idea
their perception of the message or idea
and finally their perception of the
conclusion on offer
upon outlining these reasons it should
be clear to you that the subject of your
effort would probably possess ideas that
are at least dissimilar
if not contradictory to yours and as
such the entire process would either
hinge on your persuasion being very
convincing
or the ability of the target to meet a
compromise between the conflicting ideas
that would majorly mirror the changes
you want
below are six major theories that strive
to explain the way the human mind
absorbs and reacts to information
knowledge of these would greatly
increase the odds of persuasion if you
could pinpoint it in your target
the attribution theory
this concludes that people would either
attribute actions and characters to
people and object respectively either in
relation to the context they are being
considered in or according to their own
emotional disposition
when they attribute using context as a
guide they are likely to come to
decisions that take into consideration
environment of origin and situational
factors
such as seen when a person refrains from
calling a product inferior or calling a
person insensitive instead
arguing that the product has been made
from the best possible items available
to the manufacturer
and that the person is simply reacting
as he has learned to from his childhood
environment
however when considering their own
emotional disposition they tend to
believe that whatever is convenient for
them is the only right decision or
approach for every other person
consider this situation
you meet a person at an event or
gathering and try starting a
conversation with them but instead of
giving you a polite audience the person
appears preoccupied with their own
thoughts or acts aloof
angered and annoyed you walk away and
when asked for an opinion on the person
you characterize them as proud arrogant
or
self-important
in this case the characterization you
have concluded on is based solely on
your emotional disposition and does not
take into consideration the situation or
possible problems the other person might
have
the idea is not to determine whether or
not you are wrong or right
but rather to analyze how you are likely
to process information about people and
things
you actually
might be right about the person
another situation is when you have been
accused of doing something wrong
and you claim that your accusers have
failed to see things from your own
perspective and are only interested in
their own point of view
this is a perfect example of considering
things as regards context
in this case probably because the things
said are negative you'd notice the
emphasis placed on contextual
understanding of actions
there is also a slight hint of the
dispositional thinking occurring
simultaneously
the conditioning theory
in this case the person is likely to do
things if they are tailored and
conditioned to look like their own
decisions instead of as a result of
coercion
this is most utilized in the advertising
industry where commercials
advertisements and billboards are used
to convey information that would provoke
positive feelings in the population of
interest
they then connect such feelings to their
products thus
making you feel that the product would
bring such a feeling into your life
because of this you are more likely to
purchase their product thinking all the
while that your decision was an
independent one
this is usually possible because we
generally perceive things based on our
emotions
and are more likely to buy things
because
they make us feel good
the cognitive dissonance theory
based on this theory it is assumed that
people tend to aim for consistency in
their thoughts attitudes and decisions
this is the reason why most people
create principles which they strive to
follow
most people also seem intent on
reconciling the contradictions as much
as they can
until they feel comfortable
i would give two examples on this
example one
you have a very strong and deep-rooted
need
for canned food
either due to the laziness of having to
cook meals or the frustration at having
to wait in queues for food
then you're told that such canned meals
could lead to cancer and you definitely
don't want to have cancer
but you also don't want to stop eating
canned food
so instead of stopping with the habit
you comfort yourself that
millions of people like you have the
same habit and would never have cancer
the cancer theory might be untrue but
your eagerness to dispute the fact or at
least to make the consequences seem less
severe is your own way of changing your
mind or at least making the facts you
have just learned seem less important or
true
this is one of the ways of dealing with
cognitive dissonance theory
example two
imagine a criminal
with a conscience
this is probably hard to imagine but
they do exist
in such a situation his or her criminal
tendencies are clashing with their
tender hearts and causing
a bit of discomfort
such a person is very likely dealing
with his or her problems by giving in to
the rationale that a criminal and
wealthy life far outweighs the benefits
of having a clean conscious or good
heart
again i am refraining from judging
whether such a rationale is sound but am
more focused on the fact that the person
seems to give in to a rationale that
overlaps with the general aim of most
people to deal with his discomfort
this is another way of dealing with the
cognitive dissonance
the judgment theory
this one is very simple to grasp
it simply proposes that when faced with
a new piece of information or idea a
person's reaction is more or less
dependent on the way he or she currently
feels on the topic
what this means is that we are likely to
accept something that resonates with our
current belief reject something that
doesn't fit in with our beliefs or stay
indifferent to something never
previously considered
therefore when attempting to persuade a
person it is better to first determine
their views on the topic to gauge
whether or not you'd be successful and
if your effort would eventually be worth
it
inoculation theory
the inoculation theory supports the view
that even if previously uninterested in
two points of view once argued for you
are likely to pick the dominant point of
view and stick with it
here is an example of what i mean
you have never watched a game of soccer
in your life
but one day you are relaxing on the
beach and happen to find yourself stuck
between two die-hard soccer fans who
support rival teams
an argument begins about whose team is
better and more dominant and they both
turn to you presenting their points like
you are a seasoned fan
and after some time ask you to judge on
who's better
you obviously would pick the person with
the better argument so as not to betray
your own lack of knowledge on the
subject
if in future another individual was to
pose a question to you inquiring as to
which of those two teams is better you'd
probably find yourself arguing in favor
of the choice you made then
maybe even with some of the same points
that were used then
this is the power of inoculations the
most powerful initial idea always takes
root first
narrative persuasion theory
from experience i think we would all
accept that stories have a more enhanced
effect on perception and opinions than
abstract advice
the attitudes and opinions of people
towards objects and others tend to
change when they are told compelling
stories of such subjects the theory
simply attempts to explain the
heightened effect can have on people if
utilized properly
in this the listener feels transported
and this greatly affects their
perception of events making them more
pronounced and vivid than they might
have been if they had been expressed
ordinarily and
abstractly the psychological perspective
ordinarily persuading people would be
difficult without the ability to
properly organize and present an
argument
but if an experience in any or both of
this is coupled with an inability to
gauge and understand moods and stances
your task would be made many times more
likely to fail
the ability to instantly sense and
recognize a person's stance on an issue
is difficult not to talk of performing
the same trick on an audience
because of this difficulty
most speakers who are attempting to
introduce people to a new point of view
always tend to ask questions that would
enable them to gauge the stance of the
audience before moving on with their
presentation
immediately after asking such questions
they usually watch out for visible
reactions from members of the audience
maybe a smile to indicate a previous
knowledge of the topic
sitting up to indicate interest
turning away
or sighing to indicate disagreement or
boredom or
even a person willing to answer
these simple markers give you an idea as
to how your message may be received and
would help you map out a strategy of
approach
it is also an effective tool as people
tend to express themselves more
sincerely when they do not feel
particularly in the spotlight
so if you're unsure
do not refrain from asking a few surface
questions to test the waters or more
aptly to feel out the crowd
it should also be noted that many people
might give a negative reaction to
one-on-one persuasion and would start
arguments to further their points
the moment you realize that your attempt
to persuade a particular person has
deteriorated into an argument it is
advisable for you to walk away
very few arguments occurring outside law
courts ever get settled
engaging in one would be fruitless and
time consuming that time is better spent
elsewhere
i stated earlier that manipulation is
similar to persuasion in that both aim
to change opinions attitudes and actions
from what they might have been to
whatever you prefer
and i had also stated that they differ
from one another in that persuasion is
the more direct form of securing the
change you desire while manipulation
requires you to operate in secret using
emotional exploitation
now i would like to expatiate on the
relationship between manipulation and
persuasion or
rather how persuasion can be adopted as
a tool for manipulators
this is not rocket science and needs
only a simple alteration in approach to
persuasion it would require you to
couple the ability to make compelling
irrefutable arguments with
your ability to recognize emotional
markers
once both are in sync
you are ready to move
but
why this too
the answer to that is rather simple
if you recognize an emotion to be
dominant in the target and feel the need
to convince he or she to do something
without outright manipulation
most likely due to the presence of
friends and family
wouldn't it be better to play on such an
emotion and use it as leverage or
platform with which you propel your
point of view rather than just
writing in without a strategy
this is why persuasion makes
manipulation look humane
and might even reduce the noticeability
of your ploy it enables the manipulator
you
to touch on the emotions of a target for
a reaction
but instead of making your telling moves
under a shroud all the time
you adopt clever arguments and let them
do the convincing for you
the trick however is to always get the
emotion right
chapter 6
persuasion the practical
in the previous chapter i touched upon
persuasion as a whole focusing on the
definition its differences and
similarities with manipulation as well
as their relationship and how they could
be adapted to work to your benefit as a
manipulator other than that the means by
which the human mind absorbs and relates
to new information and facts was also
discussed
now i wish to approach how the theories
of information absorption can be used to
your advantage in real life situations i
want to give you practical tips on how
to persuade people to do your bidding
effectively
putting the theories into practice
the theories from the previous chapter
were very explanatory regarding how
people are most likely to relate with
information but said very little about
how to take advantage of their
tendencies
this should give more detailed tips and
tactics as to how the theories can be
used maximally in real life situations
as well as the groups of people most
likely to possess each attribute
use of the attribution theory
this theory manifests in all people but
is more noticeable in
pseudo-manipulators or arrogant people
such people are less likely to ever
accept being wrong and are more likely
to blame it on perspective instead
here is an example on how to deal with
such people
your target is a pseudo-manipulator one
who likes to feel in control and
powerful and the roles in the
relationship are already well defined if
on a given occasion such a person were
to shut down your views in a bid to
bully you into submission you could use
such an opportunity to play for
something you need
firstly you have to avoid arguing your
point for too long or too strongly
always put up a little resistance to
emphasize their power over you
once he or she has lapsed into the role
you want for them
ask them for tips on how to do what they
want from you
be sure to keep them talking constantly
asking questions and subtly driving the
conversation towards your need when they
are at their most vulnerable they would
be ready to do anything just to keep
emphasizing their power
the thing about such targets is that
they are convinced of their powers over
you and believe themselves to be
infinitely smarter people who think
themselves smart love nothing more than
giving lectures
in which your only role is to listen and
ask more questions
once you have got them talking for an
extended period proceed to move them in
your direction of interest and when they
appear to feel at their most powerful
they are likely to grant it without too
much consideration much like the kings
of old
use of the conditioning theory
in a real life situation this theory
involves using your wit and humor to
flatter the target into believing
whatever you want them to
it also makes them more likely to
consider your suggestions
this follows the general principle that
you would aim to acquire more of what
pleases you and in this case who
a typical example is the confident guy
who prides himself on being able to pick
up a different girl every night
how does he do it
he simply wows and impresses them with a
combination of humor wit an interesting
conversation and a smoothness and style
that is very difficult to recreate he
basically makes them feel good for five
minutes at the bar
and they believe he would make them feel
equally as good for the entire night and
therefore
happily follow him out
though this works on almost everyone
naive people are bound to be more
success
use of the cognitive dissonance theory
this is a generally difficult theory to
use because the onus is usually on the
targets to make all the difference on
their lives
but if properly played and you act as
the advisor and close friend who gives
the alternative idea or compromise that
helps them deal with their dissonance
it makes you a sort of confidant
this gives you a choice position in
their lives as from their point of view
you understand them more than any other
person
this is however the sort of relationship
that must be cultivated for a period of
time before making your move
use of the judgment theory
people rich in self-confidence arrogant
and who consider themselves smarter than
most tend not to listen to or take into
consideration arguments of others that
are contradictory to their own views
if such people are to be persuaded the
new opinions they are to be inoculated
with have to be similar to their
previous ones or else all hopes of
persuading them would be impossible
if you are to ever convince them that
what they believe is wrong or inferior
to yours
you need to make it feel that acceptance
is their idea and not a necessity
the first step would be to pander to
them to defer slightly to their
intelligence
next you draw similarities between your
idea and theirs when it comes to
convincing you are better served by an
indirect approach where you ask
questions and wait for them to answer
before
gently expressing your objections making
sure to always be gentle and let their
thought processes do the job of
convincing them
it could be a change of opinion or a
need to persuade them that a course of
action better serves their interests
this method is sure to soften them up
better than arguing with them
consider that friend who sees himself or
herself as an authority on every subject
regardless of how little knowledge they
actually possess on the issue and
remember how such people almost never
back out of arguments but instead keep
going at it till the environment of the
discussion becomes toxic
we have all had this kind of friendship
and the mistake of arguing with them
even makes it harder for them to ever
change their views
this is because once they have taken a
public stance on an opinion it is
difficult for them to ever take another
or even act against what they have
supported even if they later see more
sense in your own view
this is because going back on their
belief is against their sense of pride
and their ego
thus
persuading such people is better done in
private if anything
because it gives you a chance to try
again
if you fail the first time it also gives
them a chance to adopt your idea in
public without looking weak or stupid
use of the inoculation theory this is
easy to utilize because almost everyone
is susceptible to this
the key
is making sure the person has no
previous beliefs or opinions on the
issue at hand
that is the only criterion once you are
sure of this you explain to them the
advantages of your views never forget to
also share the disadvantages but do this
in a way that it doesn't affect the
message you want them to have the reason
why the disadvantages must be made clear
is that if they associated what you have
explained to them with lies later along
the line they are very likely to change
their views as a whole
so if you need such people for the long
term make sure they have the full gist
always emphasize the advantages
and play down the disadvantages but
never conceal them
this is as such less a matter of
persuading a person as it is initiating
belief in them
for this reason knowledge and
utilization of this theory could be very
powerful in the right situations
such a situation is when you find
yourself pitching a unique and
previously utilized business idea in a
meeting or
when trying to preach a new doctrine be
it religious academic or technological
use of the narrative persuasion theory
the power of stories is well known
if you doubt it all you have to do is
think about how evangelists and
religious clerics preach their messages
are you getting the idea now though i
should probably say that these clerics
are probably among the most trained
person in the art of persuasion because
at one point they make use of so many
theories of persuasion
constantly changing their tactics to
better fit your fears and worries
but enough with the clerics
the narrative persuasion theory is
perhaps the most effective at persuading
people because it involves giving them a
story
a character that they could relate to
and then relying on that story to do
your convincing
such a story might be true or if you're
very talented made up it really doesn't
matter as long as you can get them to
listen it might not work every time when
used alone but if you were to mix it up
with other theories just like the
clerics the chances of success
are better
other techniques of persuasion
persuasion like manipulation possesses
guidelines on how best to achieve your
aim
these guidelines could be treated as
strategies or tactics and would increase
your chances of success the more you get
used to them the faster the better
use of force
the use of force or aggression could be
effective or not and more often than not
it is a win or nothing tactic
it involves not a lot of coaxing but a
lot of demanding
and as such if the person or audience
doesn't dig the vibe
there is no other means of retreating
it usually involves use of statements
that sound threatening and would most
likely be a good fit for dealing with
people with low self-confidence and
sense of self-worth also note that if
the idea is to impress friends and
family of your target
it would be better if this tactic were
used in private beyond the hearing or
view of other parties as it could easily
be perceived as bullying
commitment and consistency
these are highly respected values in the
minds of most people in all walks of
life
when coupled with a little bit of
success it could be very effective if
not the most effective means of
persuasion
if you want someone to believe your way
is gold and your opinions are equally as
rich
there is no better way than providing an
example of their successes
in most cases the best example is
usually
yourself
showing commitment to your ideas and
consistently applying them successfully
tends to convince people of their
truthfulness
it eliminates the need for you to
continue arguing your points regularly
instead
let them persuade themselves that
following your example is the right
thing it would be like seeing a
successful person and emulating them in
hopes that you'd achieve their level of
success the same way
we all do it so why not use it to our
advantage when dealing with others
another angle to this could be to get
the target to commit themselves to
promises or writing
this would be useful because most people
care about reputations and rarely want
to be seen going back on their words
while this second angle would be an
effective tool on arrogant people and
pseudo-manipulators
the first method is more likely to work
for people lacking in confidence and
self-esteem
social influence
social influence could manifest in one
of two ways
it could be positive or negative
positive influence would point to the
need for one to follow the convention or
approach that is the most common around
him or her or among friends
the negative influence on the other hand
deals with the tendency of people to act
against the norm the influence that is
expressed is usually deep rooted and
expresses itself in more than one fact
of the target's life
once the target's tendency has been
established you could move to surround
the person only with people who possess
the approach that would produce the
result you desire
this method is also applicable to people
with a low sense of self-esteem and
confidence
action by reciprocity
reciprocity generally means the need or
tendency to give back when you are given
something
you're probably wondering how this
affects persuasion
right
this is straightforward
giving something creates the need in the
target to give back
this in turn is a weakness that makes
the target more susceptible to catering
to a need that they otherwise could have
overlooked
this is also applicable to arrogant
people as well as those who possess
altruistic dispositions
an empathetic person is also likely to
fall for such a ruse this could also be
used or claimed to be used subliminally
as most times you need not even state
the need verbally or outrightly but
instead
subtly imply to its absence
use of authority or sternness
if the target is a naive person or one
who is lacking in decisiveness or
assertiveness
this is the ideal method of approach
this is for people who are prone to
listening to other people's opinions and
taking it for the truth especially when
they consider the person to be more of
an authority on the subject than they
are
it would also help if they consider your
views trustworthy and knowledgeable
this is the method of choice when
dealing with a new or junior colleague
or at least someone who is new to an
environment and is not yet well versed
in how things operate
however treating such people could also
be counterproductive causing them to
view you in a negative light
taking advantage of love
it might be a simple crush or a big
attraction but people almost always say
yes to people they like and feel
something positive for
so if you have a target that you feel is
attracted to you
play their feelings to your advantage
and ask for whatever you want
just be careful to give a little back
and do not overdo it
if the person is emotionally dependent
on you
your luck is strong because they are
even less likely to utter a word for
fear of losing you to another
the best part is that they never realize
that such is happening
as
it is a very natural reaction
leveraging your trust and integrity
if you are generally acknowledged to be
trustworthy you are more likely to be
believed this could be done by smartly
showing off your impeccable reputation
if you have one while avoiding the line
of arrogance that could spoil the effect
another way to use this tactic is to put
your character in the spotlight if you
have a good one
and making sure to back up your every
point with a vow of assurance in its
trustworthiness
the last is to give a sense of expertise
show that you possess more knowledge
than they do and when added to your
reputation and character you have a
cocktail of persuasion that even the
most steadfast of non-believers would
reconsider
it is also likely to work on naive
people and people who consider
themselves intellectual
making use of sympathy and empathy
these two emotions can easily be
manipulated because they usually convey
on their owners a sense of innocence and
docility that can be used against them
with the right words and gestures you
should be able to convince such people
of anything
for a more advanced effect make use of
stories as such people are also prone to
following the narrative transportation
theory and the combination of these two
factors make them better candidates to
believe than most
reverse psychology
reverse psychology is a technique of
persuasion where a speaker or person
utilizes a behavior or idea that is
contradictory to that which he wants to
occur
the use of this technique does or asks
for the opposite of what they actually
require of the target encouraging the
target to do as they wish
this works on people who make a habit of
resisting authority
if tried on people who are more
agreeable they might and would probably
do as you have asked
for this reason they do not make good
candidates or targets for reverse
psychology to be used upon
however even when used with resistant
people reverse psychology should be used
as subtly as possible because no one
enjoys or likes being manipulated and as
such if they recognize what you're doing
it is likely you would not achieve much
with them
an example of the use of reverse
psychology is advising someone to do
something when you know that the very
idea of the advice infuriates him or her
and would probably push them towards
doing the opposite
the idea is usually to establish the
idea you actually want them to absorb
then
play it up subtly to become tempting
before changing track and arguing
against it
immediately after this you push them to
make a decision
and that's all
it is likely they would go with it
because other than the fact that they
would want to resist the advice it is
also the idea that they were exposed to
first
it is not necessary to take such steps
if you know the person well enough to
understand what they like dislike and
how they would react in given situations
remember to always
analyze before making your move
the reason why most people fail in
persuading people into a line of action
is that they fail to grasp what is
necessary for their success and if they
do
they fail to take it all into
consideration
it is for this same reason that
persuading strangers is more difficult
than persuading people you're closer to
because if you were to ignore a person's
emotional disposition and shelf their
possible reactions it would be the same
as approaching a stranger
to really succeed at persuasion most
times you might need to adopt maybe a
dominant authoritative attitude or a
more reserved one when being
authoritative you have to give off a
vibe of knowledgeability and confidence
you must convince the person that you
know what you're speaking about while
emphasizing their own knowledge
there is a loophole here
if this is tried on a resistant person
he or she is likely to do the opposite
of what you advise and thus fall a
victim of reverse psychology you see
that knowledge of the person is
important in determining the best
technique for persuasion for without it
you would be charging blindly
you should also avoid using reverse
psychology very often as such misuse
could expose your tricks and make the
target more immune to your ministrations
it could be particularly damaging to
relationships and you do not want this
unless
that in itself is your goal
if you are to use reverse psychology
always remember to stay smart and stay
calm
do not let your emotions control you but
just like in manipulation control your
emotions
persuasion is an art that all socially
influential people crave possession of
this is because the ability to make
people do as you wish and while you can
directly manipulate individuals it
becomes trickier when dealing with
groups of people
but if you were to master this art your
power and influence would benefit
greatly
chapter 7
common manipulation techniques
at a point in our life and at least once
daily for most we resort to manipulation
to get what we want it could be a little
lie to get out of a tight spot or
harmless flattery to get yourself a
choice seat but
it is manipulation
so stop believing that manipulation is
an art reserved only for the evilest of
people everyone does it so it's simply
better to get very good at it though it
is better to look out for some traits
that predispose some to manipulation
more than others it doesn't mean that
people without such traits can't be
played
i have previously elaborated on such
traits as well as other means of gaining
control over people but it's time to
approach the real topic of discussion
how to manipulate people
lying
this is the most popular of all
manipulation techniques
on its own lying is simply misinforming
the target or at the most concealing
information from the target but when
done with a view to controlling people
it becomes a pretty powerful weapon
consider lying as a tool to soften up a
target that has until that moment proven
too strong
lying in this way would require one to
betray the very intent of conventional
lying because in this case you're not
trying to misinform or conceal but
rather to confuse
if you are to succeed at this your lies
need to be believable and contradictory
at first
at the beginning of such a ploy it is
necessary for your lies to constantly
bounce off each other creating a means
through which you could sow seeds of
confusion in someone who is usually sure
of themselves
consider lying to a partner about a past
relationship then in a later discussion
on a similar topic drop a previously
thought of slip up that contradicts the
first experiences you shared with them
the target might not notice this at
first and may require a few more similar
lies before the inconsistencies start to
call their attention but when it does
instead of defending yourself
clam up and play the victim
tell a saab's story about emotional pain
and all of that
share with them the reason for your lies
the stories and reasons might be
fictitious but the more realistic the
better
so be sure to think everything through
first
in this sort of scenario the initial
contradicting lies are needed to throw a
seemingly strong person off balance
there is nothing like a perfect person
or a truly balanced person and as such
regardless of how strong we might seem
on the outside
we all have weaknesses and there is no
better way to start the process of
exposing someone's emotional
vulnerabilities then forcing them to
instigate a heart-to-heart moment or
discussion
if you were to try creating such a
moment on your own the target would
still be likely to stay closed however
if such a discussion is their idea
whatever barriers they possessed they
would have brought down by themselves
that is the goal with this lie
it puts you in a position to change the
narrative
in a situation in which the power was
previously balanced in most of your
relations
making yourself seem weak or vulnerable
could put the target in an uncomfortable
position and force them into opening up
to adapt to their new role
just be sure to keep any contradictory
lies
out of your final story
well this might not bring you much in
terms of favors
having them believe you opened up on
some deep secret to them strengthens
their attachment they feel a stronger
bond has been formed
this trick is likely to work on people
who are emotionally secure and need to
believe you are really open with them
before
they can open up
punishment
when i say punishment i do not mean
physical abuse or violence
no i mean resorting to tactics like the
silent treatment nagging shouting or
mood swings
i know you're probably thinking how any
of these behaviors could get you any
control but if you learn to selectively
release such emotions and actions at the
right time
they could exert just the right effect
on the target the silent treatment for
example could be used to put the right
person in a state of wanting to please
you
this treatment is a popular one for
manipulators when dealing with assertive
people as well as people with low self
confidence
in such case you create a fictional
quarrel in your head that need not have
happened in reality
all it needs to be is believable and
offensive from your perspective
then follow through with the silent
treatment when the target gets desperate
to get you back to your former self
drop the act and ask for whatever you
wish for
this is a direct technique that might
not always work but for a beginner it is
worth a try and for an expert if
partnered with the right set of skills
and ploys its chances of success become
better
remember when you were little and your
parents tried keeping you away from the
candy or cookie jar and instead of
throwing a tantrum and crying you just
stalked back to your room threw the
sheets over your head and refused to
talk to anybody
you wait for hours determined not to
make the first move
and later at night your parents come
into the room bearing gifts and treats
and maybe even the promise of a trip you
want
not all children did this but most did
and yes children manipulate too
they might not recognize it for what it
is but they actually do it and since it
works they keep resorting to it again
and again
the best thing about such a ploy is at
the exact instance during which it
occurs the target believes that they are
doing the right thing to keep you happy
and keep the relationship from dying
if nagging were to be the strategy of
choice for you be sure the target is
either one who lacks assertiveness or
one who is eager to please because such
people are likely to react favorably to
nagging
let's say you want something badly
all you have to do is keep asking and
asking until they give in
due to their lack of assertiveness
through all the asking they would
probably never give you an outright no
for an answer and if it is a target who
is always eager to please
he or she would have begun considering
the pros and cons from the second time
you ask and with just a little extra
push
they would cave
mood swings are another very effective
strategy in unbalancing a target they
are just more negative than lying and if
utilized care has to be taken to avoid
dwelling too much or for too long on
negative emotions such as anger
rather it would be better to spend more
time in a neutral state of boredom or
indifference
the trick behind utilizing mood swings
is to make your target associate some
actions of theirs with particular moods
of yours this would give them an idea
about what you like and dislike without
uttering a word
it is thus advised to use this tactic
alongside a more reserved attitude
imagine your roommate tends to leave
their dishes undone after a meal
you do something drastic like throwing
such plates in the trash and then
refrain from talking much about it for
that night but when you wake the next
morning you adopt a light-hearted
demeanor and refuse to lower the smile
regardless of what he or she does
the next time your roommate invites
someone over without informing you and
you act in a similar way
you never let your reactions slip over
into the next day
and other than when the target does
something you find offensive
never react in such a way
always make sure that you do this only
rarely
depending on the type of person your
roommate is he or she would react
differently
if the person is naive or lacking in
self-esteem they would pander to you and
fail to repeat whatever it is you
reacted to
but
if the person is insensitive
your reactions would probably not do the
trick and you would have to resort to
another tactic
sarcasm and flattery
while other techniques mentioned earlier
have dealt with manipulation using
actions and acting
if you're good with words this is a more
likely weapon for you
the power of words is often under
exaggerated in favor of actions however
if mastered they could be just as useful
if not more
sarcasm and flattery are two slightly
contrasting techniques that could be
used to control the actions and opinions
of people
they are usually most effective on
someone who lacks self-esteem
such a person is likely to believe most
negative and positive things you say
about them and start working to please
you
because of this you could use sarcasm to
deliver well-planned put-downs whenever
such a person offends you
only to resort to flattery to increase
their confidence
such polarity on such a weak mind means
they would cling to you for the
compliments and flattery and would start
doing things only to please you even if
it goes against their own needs
the applications of sarcasm and flattery
lose all or at least most of their
effectiveness if they are blatantly
employed
to avoid these you must understand the
need for subtlety
in the case of sarcasm the very idea is
for you to be blatant in your execution
while subtly hiding your goal
you must make whatever comment you deem
fit without making the target feel as if
you're directing them towards a
particular line of action
failing at this could have the alternate
effect of making them immune to you
when you were young you probably
associated bullies with violence shoving
people into lockers and all but you
should be able to point out that person
who always alternated in behavior
showing you his or her good parts on one
day only to switch it up the next
the person would have been so polarizing
that people were often confused about
whether they loathed or loved him or her
and with time would start to find that
they hovered around such people trying
to cater to their every need
do you recognize them now
you probably had a few in your high
school and most times they were really
popular
two of the most effective tactics
employed by those people were sarcasm
and flattery
with subtle swipes of their tongues they
could play down your happiest moment or
your biggest achievement to be something
worthless
and in the next they could make you feel
of one of your more ordinary actions
seem spectacular as much as they hurt
your feelings you'd still find yourself
doing things they would find pleasing
whenever they were around
this might have happened to you and it
might not have but the very fact that it
happened to some speaks volumes of the
effectiveness of such tactics
so never forget to destabilize a mark
using sarcasm and flattery
another advantage of these two
techniques is that they keep you from
having to resort to trickier aggressive
or abusive techniques when slight words
and gestures would do the trick
perfectly
isolation
this is mostly a secondary tactic used
to make sure no external forces mess
with your manipulation
the presence of family and friends
around the target provide an extra level
of insulation or protection around the
target as such people tend to call the
target back on some of their actions
when they get suspicious
their presence there whispering into the
ear of the mark thus creates another
source of influence besides yours whose
sole purpose is to thwart your influence
whenever you get the target to fulfill a
need for you
such people would call he or she back
and try to expose how you are
manipulating them and that puts the ploy
you have implemented in jeopardy
on its own isolation is not that
effective but it is worth noting that in
the absence of friends and family alike
the target starts to look onto you as
their only source of advice
comfort love help etc
in other words they become completely
dependent on you emotionally and this
heightens the level of control you
possess over them this in turn makes
them easier to influence
guilt tripping and love bombing
these two are a very common duo used by
manipulators but that doesn't in any way
affect their effectiveness
guilt tripping is when you manipulate
your target's reactions making them feel
guilty about doing particular things
simply by playing on their emotional
vulnerabilities
naturally guilt is a very uncomfortable
feeling which most people strive to
eliminate
this need to eliminate their guilt after
an incident is what you should aim to
take advantage of
since such chances might be few and far
between the initiative to create
situations that give you a platform on
which you could leverage a person's
guilt against them is on you
in such a case the understanding of your
target's emotions and what makes them
tick come into play
you need to know how you can make them
feel guilty so as to take advantage of
them and their guilt
consider a situation in which a partner
or girlfriend refuses to accompany you
to a company gathering
if the gathering is not important to you
you could clam up and use a mood swing
to leverage them for something that is
but if you consider the gathering too
important to miss or you need a plus one
to impress a particular attendee
and your partner is refusing you could
play the guilt card making them feel
selfish and unkind for not considering
your needs
you would make yourself the victim
putting your partner in an awkward
position where they feel like they're
depriving you of something you need for
their own selfish reason
when this is used on less assertive
people or people lacking in
self-confidence the result is usually
stunning as more often than not
they end up doing exactly what you want
they might even outperform your
expectations
simply because of their need to
eliminate the feelings of guilt you have
created in them
using such a tactic you rile up someone
that loves or is attached to you by
telling them and claiming that they do
not care or are too selfish in the way
they treat you
this would keep an emotionally
vulnerable person in check making them
see you as the victim of their actions
rather than the other way around
they would then be eager to prove your
claims wrong thus
increasing in them the need to please
love bombing on the other hand is a
technique in which you continuously and
over an extended period of time
shower a person with love impressing
them with charm while getting whatever
you want from them
this is usually much difficult to tell
apart from real love
and that's what makes the mark even more
vulnerable
love bombing is effective on almost
everyone because as humans we all love
to feel good and this need drives our
selection of the people we hang out with
if someone makes us feel loved and cared
for we impulsively strive to spend more
time with them
this would also mean that the target
would feel more inclined to satisfy your
need in order to maintain his or her
happiness
however
like most tactics the effect of love
bombing is more pronounced in some
character types
what this means is that depending on the
level of love bombing you expose a
target to
some would see it as a result of you
trying to be nice and would consider you
a good friend
while others would see your actions as
more and would consider you as
more than a friend
individually love bombing and
guilt-tripping are effective but when
combined they are devastating i am yet
to explain reinforcement but the effect
they produce is quite similar
to achieve such an effect you should
probably expose the target to your
loving and charming side
make the effort of your love felt then
when the moment is right you withdraw it
and leave the target craving for it the
next step is to up the ante by making
them feel guilty about your withdrawal
you make them feel like your current
mood and state is their fault and when
you feel that they are ripe and ready to
accommodate your whims and needs you
slowly slip back into the role of loving
and caring for them
most of the time this works and its
success is because every time you put
both ploys in play you create a sort of
hypersensitivity to your needs and wants
in the target you get them into a state
where all they want to do is return to
the period of time when all you did was
love them and charm them
you might also resort to completely
playing the victim just to make the
target more uncomfortable and guiltier
softening them up for whatever it is
that you actually want of them
this is the technique used by con men
and women who want to take advantage of
vulnerable people and make some wealth
for themselves in the process
they invile their ways into the lives of
such people and then
love bomb them to the point where the
target cannot imagine an extended period
of time without them and would for that
reason alone do anything to keep them
happy
whenever they fail to get their way they
would then resort to guilt-tripping in
order to bring the target back into a
state of mind in which their major
thought would be on pleasing them
it might seem odd and unbelievable but
if you think about it long enough you'd
realize that these two are the most used
techniques by
gold diggers and emotional swindlers
reinforcement
this technique is easy to understand but
hard to actually apply and as such is
better learned by trial and error
in this ploy you provide the target with
whatever he or she wants be it money
gifts sex or companionship provided it
is within your capability
and after the person grows accustomed to
having what you give them
you begin the process of constantly
withdrawing and providing them with
these constantly keeping them on their
toes and making them more vulnerable
with you the major trick here is
figuring out what the target wants what
makes them tick or what most tickles
their ego
you have to identify that weakness that
everyone has
and reinforce it it might be praise and
recognition the person desires give it
to them
it might be money and gifts give it to
them
it might be sex or prestige give it to
them but whenever you feel they are not
conforming to your whims or are not
taking care of your needs
or are even daring to take you for
granted withdraw all that you have given
to them and in a bid to get it all back
they would come groveling and begging
after the first time they would probably
learn to satisfy your every want if they
don't want you withdrawing your
reinforcement
for example there is at least a smidgen
of materialism in all of us and this can
be taken advantage of
if you meet a lady whose weakness lies
in her love of material possessions and
you have the money to spend you are in
luck
all you have to do is charm her take her
on a few shopping trips spend your money
on her and basically reinforce her love
of material things
upon every reinforcement try upping the
ante on the things you ask of her you
could start with insisting she spend
more time with you
insisting she accompany you to any event
you wish and with time you could try
asking her
or commanding her to stay over whenever
you like
to keep up the supply of riches love for
which you have reinforced her she would
most likely conform to your needs or at
least beg for a reprieve rather than
reject you
but if she seems to take your kindness
for granted
kick her to the curb and withdraw your
reinforcement
she is likely to come back had in hand
apologizing for her behavior
and eager to please
not to restrict this to only your love
life this technique could also be
applied to almost any setting including
business family relationships and any
case in general provided there exist a
means by which you reinforce the
individual or group involved
if you think about it you would notice
that there really is little difference
between this and
parents who threaten to ground you and
take away your freedom unless you behave
as they wish
or businessmen who pull out of deals
with established customers in the hope
of pushing them into making desperate
unfavorable deals that would benefit
them
in the case of the parents they have
reinforced your love of freedom by
allowing you to do the things you like
most of the time
this when coupled with our inherent need
to be free makes us eager to please them
anytime they threaten to take that
freedom away
couple the love for freedom with the
fact that they are your providers of
everything you need
and you would see that they have quite
the hold on you
as i implied earlier manipulation is
rife in the world
and silently hoping for an ideal world
in which it doesn't exist would make no
difference it is better you wisen up and
get better at it than others before you
are taken on a ride i left this as the
last technique on my list because there
is a possibility or rather an inevitable
reaction that you always have to take
into consideration when dealing with
people
this is ingratitude or sometimes boredom
people tend to take for granted things
they have all the time and over a long
period of time they are bound to get
bored
to avoid this you would need to be very
good at utilizing multiple techniques at
various times on the same target
this in gratitude or boredom is most
likely to occur when reinforcement is
used and to counter this reaction you
must understand that whatever you're
reinforcing in the target could make
them take you for granted
because of this you must always be ready
to withdraw your reinforcement not only
when they misbehave but also
when you like to
this sounds mean and selfish and it
actually is
but you need to know that for
reinforcement to work you need to be
selfish
you have to make the target see your
needs as being more important than
theirs and to successfully do this
selfishness is necessary
the target needs to know that your
efforts at making them feel good come at
a price and the price is
anything you want in return
thus
being nice doesn't cut it here
you need to be mean sometimes to truly
make it work for you
manipulation is not always for the
faint-hearted
manipulation
is not always wrong nor is it always
right but one thing that can be agreed
upon is
that it leaves an effect on both the
user and the target
depending on how manipulation was used
the effect might be positive or negative
manipulation is usually used as a means
of harming subduing or using a person
usually in a way that benefits the
manipulator
mostly at the expense of the target
the negative effects of manipulation are
not experienced by the victim alone and
in most cases the users are not aware of
the negative effects their behavior is
having on their lives and thus become
victims of their own manipulation
one of the problems of manipulation is
the transfer or possession of power
power is naturally very addictive and
very corrupting so when faced with the
question of what to use the power you
have over people for
people tend to think about their selfish
needs and how to make them happen
the idea of having power over a group of
people or person is tempting and when
such power is gotten it can lead to
complete subordination and even abuse
while that is an effect on the victim
the user of such power might also become
dependent on it thus
making it difficult for them to have any
sort of relationship with anybody
unless they have power to exert
this can be damaging both
psychologically and emotionally in the
long run
chapter 8
mastering the art of subtlety do not be
blatant
if manipulation isn't subtle it probably
wouldn't be effective
the very idea of manipulation thrives on
the ability to subtly plant ideas
thoughts and opinions in the mind of the
target and frame it in such a way that
they believe that such ideas are the
best they could come up with or the
right thing to do
subtlety is necessary because the target
has to feel that your every action is
natural and actually not intended to
influence them
this would mean that you first have to
reduce the frequency with which you
manipulate them
manipulating them would mean reacting
regularly in a negative way to what they
do
this might seem unnatural to the target
and could even lead them into believing
that you're always trying to push on
their buttons which
by the way you are
the ability to be subtle is as important
as the ability to read emotions because
subtlety makes your knowledge of their
emotions and reactions remain unknown to
them
being blatant in the way you manipulate
a person would also draw the attention
of other people such as friends and
family and in all honesty there is
hardly a better way to put your
manipulation of a target in jeopardy
than exposing them to the influence of
their family and friends
the simple secret to being subtle
is to keep your judgments to yourself
and keep your actions and reactions as
cool and as undetectable as possible
the cautious approach is always best
regardless of how vulnerable a target
might seem or how susceptible to
manipulation they might look from a
distance
it is necessary for you to approach the
idea of manipulating a person cautiously
it isn't ever something to jump into
just because of the possibility that the
manipulation could be successful
cautiousness has to extend to all areas
of the manipulation from the planning to
the approach and everything in between
this is especially important when
dealing with strangers or people with
whom you haven't spent that much time
with
the emotions of such people are usually
difficult to follow even for the experts
and as such
it is better to proceed with utmost
caution at first and consolidate on the
little progress you make
the same thing applies when dealing with
people you know
because even though the chances of you
getting it wrong is very slim it still
exists and for this reason you have to
consider your actions before going on
with them otherwise you risk destroying
your relationships
another problem with throwing caution to
the wind is that it exposes your tactics
and your goal to the target
while some people might just cut you
loose and move on with their lives
others might feel the need to expose you
to a dose of your own medicine
such people would probably try to
manipulate you in return with a view at
causing you pain
so if the need to succeed does not make
you cautious maybe
thinking about your own well-being
does the trick
a flimsy ploy is ineffective
other than the ability to actually go
through with the manipulation
another thing to pay attention to is the
solidity of the ploy
this consists of details such as the
rightness of the strategy to be utilized
as regards the emotional and
psychological disposition of the target
as well as the situation in which you
find yourself in
the technique applied always has to seem
like a natural reaction to whatever
situation you find yourself in
if the reaction is unnatural
the ploy might still work out but if
looked at closely what you're doing
would become more visible to the target
and more so to outsiders who lack the
emotional dependence the target has for
you
for this reason no matter who the target
is or how long the relationship has been
going on for
you always need to make sure that the
manipulation is foolproof and that no
one is the wiser to your plans
scouting out the right target and
putting the right approach into play
would be useless if the general ploy is
easily seen through
the ploy has to consist of you yourself
the image you're portraying to the
target how the role you are playing
interacts with your actions and most
importantly the fluidity of the entire
ploy
if any of this is found lacking or for
some reason the various elements are
found to be out of sync with one another
the chances of success reduce
considerably
never get ahead of yourself
the ability to keep yourself on track
and put your mind to the task even when
things are going well for you is an
important attribute in every facet of
life
regardless of how well the relationship
might be for you at a particular time or
how much the manipulation is serving
your interests
never ever lose track of yourself
a loss of concentration could manifest
in many ways it could be a tendency for
you to lose hold of your target a need
to avoid subtlety or the urge to fast
track a ploy
any of these is risky as it exposes you
to a better chance of failure which in
turn could lead to a complete breakdown
of your plan
you must always stay alert to your
surroundings and the reactions of your
target to them you must never fail to
recognize how a situation affects a
target or else you risk losing them
prematurely
never go all out
unless
subtlety is a rule most manipulators
always conform to
the ones who choose to not obey this are
often less successful and when they
succeed their success is usually
short-lived
we have established the need for secrecy
and subtlety but there are times when
being subtle is disadvantageous or not
as effective as being blatant
in these cases you are advised to apply
the needed pressure where necessary
the ability to recognize when a
situation requires more pressure than
finesse as well as the best way to
deliver such pressure is one garnered
through experience and failure
situations that could call for the
application of pressure are numerous
but you must be able to determine if the
pressure is actually necessary and how
to apply it
one such situation is the need to keep a
target when you feel they are slipping
away
for example
you have been working at target for a
while you have done everything by the
book maintaining isolation staying on
guard and generally looking out for any
potential spoilers while getting what
you want from the target
then
in comes an old friend who is not so
charmed by you
this friend goes on the attack trying to
pull the target from your clutches and
you have really worked to get to this
point
you don't want to stop now
then to bring your target back you do
something drastic like
proposing marriage
this is the sort of pressure i am
talking about
in such a situation you would agree that
all other more subtle methods might and
probably had already failed under such a
spirited assault from the friend
but instead of pulling out and walking
away you do the one thing that would
express your desperation to keep the
target close to you
saying this here makes it look like
showing desperation is a bad thing
but from the point of view of the target
it convinces them of the truthfulness of
your affection
if such a friend truly suspected of
manipulation she would have most likely
used your avoidance of true commitment
to prove her point and such an act would
completely vilify their views and
opinions in the eye of the target
chapter 9
practical uses of manipulation
manipulation as a tool is quite
versatile as it does not particularly
have any situations that it is
restricted to
what this means is that as long as
people are involved in whatever you are
involved in be it a business setting a
relationship or whatever
manipulation can be used to further your
agenda
manipulation in business
the knowledge of manipulation and
persuasion is critical if you plan to
avoid being drawn into office politics
not of your making or if you're out to
avoid being cheated or railroaded by
superiors and colleagues alike
also in business settings there is a
need for members of the same
organization or group to confirm their
views with one another and influence
each other to cater to the group's
interests
the ability to persuade people that your
point of view is best would be quite
handy in such a scenario
sales people also need to be well versed
in the arts because most times they deal
with people who believe them to be
swindlers and for that reason they need
to manipulate the person's perception of
them creating a positive one
before they could then begin the process
of persuading such a customer to try out
their products
there are some informal rules to follow
when practicing manipulation in such
business settings
one
don't push the limits
when i say limits i do not mean yours i
mean that of the people you are
manipulating one of the ways that people
push the limit is by trying to
manipulate everyone
every time
while this might work effectively in a
relationship in an organization everyone
watches everyone closely and being
associated with a tendency to manipulate
people does not do your credibility much
good
you have to be smart enough and
disciplined enough to refrain from doing
anything unless it is important
you have to always pick your battles
well
if you overdo it and people start to
view you as a manipulator
they start to monitor your every move
and even the most mundane of your
actions become an object of intense
scrutiny
such scrutiny would make it a whole lot
more difficult for you to achieve
anything when it truly matters 2.
sharpen your senses
senses in this sense mean the ability to
listen and to watch others
in a business setting the ability to
listen and perceive the disposition of
others and so when possible say nothing
take a back seat and let others have the
floor
due to the fact that everybody in such a
setting is always trying to get ahead of
the next it would be better if you could
discern their strategies and goals and
there is no better way to achieve that
by putting yourself in a position to
hear and see everything
three
create a connection be it a customer or
a colleague you have to build a
connection with them
most people make the mistake of
believing that they only need to build
connections with their bosses
but this line of action would only serve
to paint you as your boss's stooge
and alienate you from your fellow
workers
on the contrary
forging a bond with both your colleagues
and your bosses would make them see you
as more of a bridge
and less of a stooge
another need for such a connection is
the fact that you're more likely to be
in the position to influence the
thoughts and opinions of people when
they feel they have a connection with
you then if they consider you a complete
stranger
this is particularly important when
you're pitching an idea to others and
its absence is the major reason why cold
pitching is a very difficult trick to
pull off
four
always stay neutral
when you can
in a business setting neutrality should
be your best strategy
never take sides unless
you have utmost confidence as to which
side possesses more power
taking sides early on would strip you of
your flexibility and limit you to
working only one angle
you must be adept at playing both sides
until you recognize which side would
come out on top
the right way to maintain neutrality is
to acknowledge the talents of everyone
equally while also expressing real views
regarding their failures
other than strengthening your position
of neutrality such a tactic would also
earn you the respect of everyone however
like every other tactic you have to know
when to apply this and this knowledge
would be the difference between you
successfully holding your position or
even advancing in the ranks and you
failing spectacularly
manipulation in relationships
manipulation in relationships is the one
society is most sensitive about
if you manipulate in the office most
people outsiders would view it as a
general tactic used by many in the same
position but
manipulating in a relationship is in the
eye of most
a negative marker on the character of
the manipulator
regardless of whether your intentions
are pure or selfish this opinion does
not change and it is for this reason
that whatever plan you have for a spouse
or close friend must be done in utmost
secrecy
this brings us to a previously stated
point
isolation
isolation is one of the most important
factors to be considered if you want
your manipulation of a person to be
successful
you must wean the target off their
family and friends establishing yourself
as their confidante and emotional
companion
this is because the external influence
exercised by such people is capable of
rivaling that which you have created and
rendering your plans a waste of time
another thing to pay attention to is
your intention
you must be disciplined check yourself
and make sure that your needs from the
target do not morph into complete
selfishness
you must learn to control and wield the
power you possess over them with caution
and with sense
to avoid causing them harm
this is only possible if you think
beyond your own needs and ask yourself
if your need might lead to any negative
consequences for the target and if so
how serious such consequences would be
manipulation is a very powerful tool and
should be treated as such
manipulating a friend
of all settings for manipulation this is
the most popular and the least
suspicious or revolting
manipulating a friend is so common we
barely pay attention to it
it usually manifests when we want to get
information or something out of one
another
the best and easiest method of
manipulating friends is through the use
of reciprocity and compliments
sometimes we do favors for friends
because we want to but we also grant
difficult favors not because we want to
but because we recognize that we might
need something equally as difficult to
grant in the future
you do not always have to do big things
it might be a couple of smaller favors
but having them in the bag means you
could leverage on reciprocity later in
the future
beware of insensitive or particularly
selfish people because they tend not to
conform to reciprocity
except it favors them in the moment
the use of compliments is another way by
which we unknowingly and harmlessly
manipulate ourselves
the compliment might be sincere or
insincere but when we give them we
recognize that they make our friends
feel better about whatever it is they
might have done making them more likely
to make us feel better too
whether by returning such compliments
or by other means offering support
sort of falls under reciprocity but it
is still valid as a standalone point
we might argue that offering our support
to our friends in arguments and in their
time of need is the right thing to do
but even when we think they are wrong we
rarely ever withdraw our support
why
this is because when we have arguments
or times when we need support we
recognize the need to have someone in
our corner and who better than someone
who we offer unconditional support to
when they need it
you can see that the manipulation is
usually unintentional and harmless
but it is still a manipulation because
if faced with the same choice when
another person is involved
such a friend would probably do what
they feel is right and not what you need
in this way you can see that the need to
reciprocate the support you showed has
altered their behavior and reactions
seductive manipulation
like cleopatra's manipulation of both
julius caesar and mark anthony this
involves using your sexuality and
possible sexual prowess as a tool in
getting whatever it is you need from a
target
while this is an effective method it
also doesn't last that long if you can't
get the target to develop more tangible
feelings for you
the truth is that there is a limit to
how long sex can hold a person down
and because of this it is better to
initially play hard to get
this has the double effect of making
them mistake their lust for a more
potent feeling while also pushing them
to impress you just to get closer to
achieving their target which is
having you
the key is in the timing
you have to be able to realize when the
target might be losing interest and also
recognize the steps you have to take to
reignite their interest
finally you have to know when to give in
it would be better for your ploy if you
have the sexual prowess to match your
games as this would make you less of a
pretender and more of the real deal
if properly played a game of seductive
manipulation could lead to real feelings
and would thus make the target even more
dependent on you
everyone is susceptible to this sort of
manipulation because we all crave
emotional and physical relationships
with others regardless of how small the
urge is
how to properly manipulate strangers
strangers are the hardest to manipulate
or persuade because you usually have no
idea how they think how they process
information or what makes them tick
in fact most of the time when you
approach a stranger you find yourself
following your instincts and searching
for a foothold in their minds that you
can leverage into a real connection
this is the smart way to go when dealing
with individuals you barely know but
such a method is slow and could end up
being frustrating
the alternative is quicker riskier and
used mostly by pickup artists
it is one in which you walk up to the
target and impress he or she with an
intoxicating mix of charm wit
and the promise of a very interesting
future
this plan could fall by the wayside if
your version of humor doesn't click with
theirs or if your target is in the wrong
state of mind for your ploy to have an
effect
another way is to go all out and state
what you want
this is rarely utilized mostly because
it betrays the very essence of
manipulation secrecy and emotional
control
it is also
rarely successful
so unless you are feeling lucky or the
universe seems to be in your corner
don't try it
chapter 10
manipulating and scouting the forgotten
connection
i like to compare the game of
manipulation to the hunting rituals of a
predator while hunting a prey when
hunting prey the lions of the african
savannah watch their unfortunate prey
say a herd of wildebeests grazing in the
distance
the lions usually a pride
lie in weight studying the unsuspecting
prey
analyzing the herd and seeking out the
weak and the vulnerable of the herd
pretty much scouting the herd
after successfully picking a target
the lions then plan a mode of attack
assigning the roles of distraction and
decoys to certain individuals of the
pack
some to cut off the escape routes of the
prey and finally one or more to finally
bring down the prey
the manipulation game isn't too
different from the scenario explained
above
when scouting the idea is not to hide or
to skulk in the dark but rather to size
up your target emotionally and
psychologically
it is the process by which you identify
the initial footholds present in their
minds and how they could be used to your
advantage
naturally when starting the process of
manipulation with a stranger you are
usually starting out blind but when you
skip the scouting phase all together you
can sign yourself to starting out on the
weakest possible footing
further reducing your chances of
succeeding
watching your target is important
this is the first step and the very
foundation of manipulating a target
as shown by the hunting lions watching
or studying gives you a basic info on
the target helping you understand the
target's habits likes and dislikes wants
and aspirations of such target that can
be exploited
things that would prove useful in your
arsenal for securing the target
a knowledge of the relevant basic info
of a target reveals the weak points of
such target providing spots to be
exploited and to get what is needed and
knowing how to trigger such target to
get the required result
a good example of those weak points is
the human emotions
as humans a considerable amount of us
tend to act and make decisions under the
influence of our emotions and are as a
result
slaves to our emotions emotions make a
man because they are his basest truest
reactions to his situation and most of
the time we fall victim to our own
emotions expressing them without control
and as such
leaving us exposed to the ministrations
and knowledgeable tweaking of
manipulators
as earlier implied you must always
reserve extreme control over your own
emotions and to judge every situation
logically
this helps you make the right decisions
in every situation and also protects you
from manipulation
as you are the only one with the
knowledge of your feelings
these emotions can act as catalysts to
the decision-making process of the human
mind without a lot of us realizing it
for example an altruistic person that
selfless individual who wants to do
right by everyone
such persons need to satisfy everyone
can be exploited by the classic guilt
trip move by making them feel sad and
unfulfilled and making them do what you
want
the knowledge gleaned from watching a
target cannot be underestimated it
should be one of immense importance to
your initial actions concerning such a
target guiding your action and words
establishing trust
the importance of trust in manipulation
can never be overstated it is like the
key which finally opens a door to a lost
store of gems and treasures
just like without the key you have no
access to the treasures which lay inside
so can you not truly manipulate a person
without gaining their trust
this is the mistake made by
pseudo-manipulators and you would do
well not to make similar ones
they make the mistake of misjudging how
much the target trusts them and as such
show their hand too early
as a result
they are exposed to manipulation
themselves because
they then trust every one of your
actions and words to be as a result of
their influence
trust has always been an active and
essential ingredient for a successful
human relationship
a child trusts its parents that is why
he or she can follow such parent to
anywhere without fear for harm
so it is with the targets of
manipulation
once you have secured their trust
you become infallible your decisions are
regarded to be accurate and your word is
held in highest regard
in some cases this trust is easily
gotten like in the instance of the
altruistic good willing and generally
naive people
but in other cases it is not always
gotten so easily as one might have to go
through various tests to finally earn
that trust
but
once the trust is finally earned
it is always worth the effort you
basically have them in the palm of your
hand at this level and they are as clay
in the hands of a potter in your own
hands ready to bend to whatever
direction you may wish
the subject of trust is also a critical
one as trust is as easy to lose as it is
hard to gain
a couple of mistakes could easily cause
you to lose the hard-earned trust of a
target and
trust when lost
isn't always exactly gotten back even if
it is gotten back
it is never always in full
planning a strategy of approach
most of the time for any endeavor to be
successful you need a strategy
referencing the predator-prey scenario
earlier stated a strategy is a means
towards an end or ultimate result
the word strategy brings the game of
chess to mind
every smart player knows that to win a
strategy must be in place to achieve
such result
if trust is the key to a den of
treasures then your strategy is your
plan to avoid the uncanny traps placed
around to prevent seekers from reaching
the treasure
the manipulation of a target has now
become like a game of chess where your
every move must be tailored and aimed to
getting what you want
it has become a game which for every
action of the target there should be a
suitable reaction on the part of the
manipulator to help get what is needed
since human beings can be quite
dissimilar in terms of constitution
intelligence and emotional makeup
it goes without saying that one strategy
cannot work for all and different
strategies should be employed for
different targets and different
occasions
one can choose to work a target little
by little slowly but surely getting the
required result or
one could alternatively leave a bait
for the target
and wait patiently for the bite
the strategy applied must take into
consideration the default emotional
state of the target the level of
isolation of the target
the peculiarities of the person as well
as the general nature of the person
all of this are very important and
neglect of anyone could lead to failure
follow only what you see or hear
this is in a way related to the first
point
watching and studying the target would
provide you with clues to exploit when
working at target
these clues should be your pointers
guiding you on the next step to take or
what to say next
but contrary to the first point this is
a warning
you should never try to use a clue or a
feeling not present in a particular
target against him or her
as humans we possess the tendency to
judge people based on what we would do
in their shoes and not based on what
they have shown they would do
you have to kick out this tendency as it
could mess with your reactions to the
target's actions even without clouting
your judgment
it makes you doubt the soundness of your
judgment pushing you to react against
what you would do and feel
instead of what you can observe the
target
doing or feeling
indiscriminate or excessive use of such
could put you in trouble and you could
ruin the whole process
causing you to start the whole process
all the way from the beginning
never forget the idea behind a
successful manipulation is
determining the targets emotional state
and reactions and using this to your
advantage
never let doubt creep in and spoil what
is already almost done
only follow what you can see and hear
and nothing else
chapter 1
introduction to dark psychology
it's a bit of a well-kept secret that
the ability to manipulate people is a
useful tool it's one of the reasons how
businessmen and politicians get and hold
their positions
there comes a certain point in your life
wherein completely turning off your
emotions and being pragmatic is a skill
you need to have
nobody likes to discuss it because we
have this societal fear of the reality
that people can just be seen as a means
to an end
the late steve jobs was particularly
renowned for his ability to work with
people's emotions and to say just the
right thing that would get them to come
around to his view
it was so strong in fact that the people
around him developed their own term for
it the
reality distortion field
phrase coined from a similar phenomenon
in the star trek universe
there are numerous historical instances
of steve jobs taking advantage of his
unique ability to get precisely what he
wanted one such instance was when jobs
in the 1980s was trying to get pepsi ceo
john scully to come to apple
this exchange spawned a famous line that
many know today
quote do you want to sell sugared water
for the rest of your life
or do you want to come with me
and change the world
end quote
there is a lot to be said about his
specific ability to charm and manipulate
people not the least of which was his
deep understanding of what people wanted
as well as what people wanted to hear
add on to this an understanding of
subtle intimidation power cues and a
large amount of passion and charisma
and you have a powerhouse who could get
pretty much whatever he wanted
how does all of this apply to you well
you're reading this because you want to
learn how to work with people from the
inside out
you want to know how to say just the
right thing to get what you need and how
to manipulate people such that you can
bypass any obstacles so they will do
exactly what you want
if that's the case
then you've come to the right place
the fact is that the mind is a
relatively simple thing while the brain
is infinitely complex the manifestations
of the conscious mind are both resolute
and easy to work with
most people work in very obvious and
predictable ways such that if they're a
normal person you can rather easily
figure out the best way to work with
them in no time flat
the purpose is to analyze all of these
patterns within the context of people in
general so that you can learn the best
way to put these trends to use
some people will
of course
break these
standard molds and for this reason there
are a couple chapters dedicated to the
idea of knowing the person you're
working with reading their inner and
outer body language and mental cues and
knowing how to build a paradigm that you
can easily manipulate them with in the
end this is about using the concept of
neuro-linguistic programming to its
fullest to get what you want out of
people
a more common term for this is
manipulation
however the aim of neuro-linguistic
programming is slightly different
neuro-linguistic programming is more
focused on the long-term shifting of
attitudes where manipulation is more
based on immediate gains
that isn't to say that neuro-linguistic
programming isn't a form of manipulation
though it absolutely is
when you hear the term manipulation you
will probably have some sort of
knee-jerk reaction like wait isn't
manipulation wrong
and to this question
there is no simple answer
i have to say
no
though
manipulation isn't wrong
manipulation is simply a tool
how you use it can determine whether
it's wrong or not
for example an example of manipulation
being objectively wrong is doing
something that gets somebody terribly
hurt
there are also some unspoken rules that
you should never break for example while
it's pretty easy to take advantage of
the fact that somebody's parent is dying
actually doing so
is a major ethical gray area
if you stick to maintaining an ethical
approach then manipulation actually
proves itself as a method of
understanding people and knowing how to
work with them so things will work out
better for you
you can even use manipulation for good
purposes one such example is steve jobs
yet again who used his reality
distortion field for good causes such as
when he would convince his employees
that it was possible to do something
that was more or less
impossible which in turn would make them
work harder for the end result and
eventually led to a new mark being set
in technology
we all know that psychology is the study
and analysis of the human mind and human
behavior
so
what is
dark psychology
it is the science and art of
manipulating and controlling the human
mind through various methods
psychology is central to human
interactions thoughts and actions
whereas dark psychology involves the use
of tactics of persuasion motivation
coercion and manipulation to get what
you want
there is a phenomenon in this realm
referred to as the dark psychology triad
that consists of elements that help in
detecting potential criminal behavior in
people
the dark triad is a combination of
traits using narcissism machiavellianism
and psychopathy
what are the characteristic features of
each of these dark triad traits
narcissism is related to lack of empathy
high levels of egotism and grandiosity
machiavellianism people with this
attitude have little or no sense of
morality and ruthlessly employ
manipulation and other tactics to
exploit and or deceive others
psychopathy
these people come across as very
charming and charismatic and deep down
are highly impulsive selfish lack
empathy and are fairly remorseless
yes it is true that none of us wants to
be manipulated and yet it happens in our
daily lives with unerring regularity
many times unwittingly
additionally we also use mind control
and manipulation tactics to try and get
what we want
dark psychology involves studying the
psychodynamics of people who prey on and
victimize others to achieve their own
needs
there are people who use dark psychology
tactics knowingly and with the intention
to cause harm to others and there are
those who use or are pray to these
tactics in unwitting ways moreover it is
a survival instinct in all living beings
to be wary of our surroundings and use
guile and deception to survive and
thrive
there are multiple studies that prove
this innate ability to victimize others
although we believe that we have control
over our actions and reactions under
extreme pressure it is very difficult to
predict our behaviors and there are high
chances that many employ dark tactics to
escape from these pressures
the following studies are examples of
how human minds behave in unpredictable
ways when compelled or sometimes even
when it may not have needed such an
extreme reaction
let us look at some of these experiments
conducted in the 60s and 70s by
psychologists
while there are controversies
surrounding the experiments and
plausible rationalizations were provided
in retrospect it goes without doubt that
the human mind can be very unpredictable
and is capable of reaching out to its
dark aspects with little or no
provocation
the learner
was actually only an actor
if the learner gave a wrong answer the
volunteers were told to give electric
shocks by turning the dial
which had labels ranging from mild pain
to extreme pain to even fatal pain
the experimenter wearing a lab coat told
the volunteers that they should continue
to increase the intensity of the
electrical shock until the right answer
was given by the learner
the volunteers could hear the simulated
screams of the learner from the other
room if the volunteer did not want to
increase the intensity then the
experiment told them to continue
employing the current statements
please continue
the experiment needs you to go on
it is essential that you go on
you have no choice you have to go on
there were startling and disturbing
outcomes from this rather controversial
experiment
despite hearing the simulated screams of
extreme pain from the learners 65
percent of the volunteers turned the
knob to fatal
they did not even bother to ask about
the health of the learner yet most of
the volunteers said that they would have
never behaved this way but
did not find the wherewithal to stand up
to a figure of authority lab-coated
experimenter
dark psychology is easy to trigger
isn't it the most disturbing observation
of these kinds of experiments was the
fact that the volunteers were not even
aware that they were being manipulated
and that they were delving into the dark
aspects of their mind
another study which proved the
unconscious behavior under authority
goes as follows
a group of volunteers was asked to watch
a screen in which a basketball game was
going on
they were told to count the number of
passes that took place between players
wearing white shirts
at some point during the game a person
dressed in a gorilla costume walked into
the court
the participants were so engrossed in
counting the number of passes that they
did not even notice this aberration in
fact
many participants swore that no such
disturbance took place
they were unconsciously following the
orders of the experimenter
another common dark psychology tactic is
called priming
in which people's behaviors can be
changed without them even realizing it
for example
read this sentence quote
the house was so old that it groaned
creaked and struggled to stand on its
shaky foundation
end quote
now suppose you were to stand up chances
are very high that you will
unconsciously have taken care to do so
at a slower pace than usual as you were
just now
primed
for old age
politicians are known to use priming to
change voting preferences based on the
location of the booth
like this there are many studies which
prove that accessing and employing the
dark side of our minds is not just easy
but can happen without us even being
aware of it
moreover these theories have been
applied and checked repeatedly
throughout the history of mankind and
dark psychology is an integral part of
our minds
this is not the same as conspiracy
theories
dark psychology only represents the
innate need and desire for man to
dominate over others who are weaker than
himself so as to achieve his own needs
marketing advertisements are classic
examples of manipulating the minds of
the buyers and convincing them to buy
the product which they may or may not
need
therefore it makes sense to know
understand and appreciate this aspect of
our minds and use strategies and tips to
prime our minds and those of others in
ways that will result in win-win
situations for all concerned
stakeholders
persuasion persuasion is one of the most
popular forms of mind control
this method is used in so many different
areas of life that many people don't
even recognize when it is happening
that is exactly why it works
persuasion is not the same as convincing
although most people believe the two are
the same thing
however persuasion is the act of
skillfully encouraging someone to do
what you want them to do without them
realizing you're doing it
whereas convincing someone means that
you're using tactics that are easy to
recognize
to explain it a bit further
persuading means to skillfully present
facts and information in a way that
doesn't make it obvious that you're
doing so and encouraging people to do
what you desire for them to do
convincing people on the other hand is
very obvious and often includes a lot of
back and forth and ultimately nagging
begging or pleading someone to make the
decision you want them to make after
they have already chosen the alternative
when you're learning about persuasion it
may seem easy in reality it is a
strategy that requires a lot of time
effort and practice you cannot simply
read about persuasion and then
run out and master it instead you really
need to ensure that you grasp the
concept and that you practice putting it
into action in your daily life
in chapter six you will learn about many
real life strategies that can help you
further integrate this technique into
your life
manipulation
manipulation tends to be regarded as one
of the darker methods of mind control
and many people think it is a nasty
thing to do
however
when you learn to use manipulation
properly you can use it to gain control
over virtually anyone's mind and have
your desired effect on their decisions
and actions
unlike persuasion which is typically
comprised of conversational tactics
manipulation involves external
influences to help encourage people to
do what you want them to do
these include strategies like building
trust and proving why they should do
what you want them to do
while some of these strategies are
conversational they are often impacted
by external influences unlike persuasion
which relies merely on wording structure
and methods of structuring your
sentences and conversations
deception
deception is an extremely sophisticated
strategy that is used in mind control
this is not the process of outright
lying to people but rather
tactfully covering up certain pieces of
information to avoid them from ever
being discovered
this strategy allows people to knowingly
omit information from conversations
without being considered liars since
they have never directly been asked and
therefore they have never directly lied
when you're partaking in deception you
have to be tactful and consistent in
keeping the conversation away from any
question that may put you in a position
where you must either come clean or
actually lie
using deception as a secondary
manipulation method for mind control
purposes means
controlling the conversation and
preventing it from ever going in the
direction that would suggest information
that you are lying or covering up
information in order to skillfully use
deception you need to know how to guide
the conversation in a way that leads the
listener to believe something without
ever actually being told to believe it
for example if you want to prevent
someone from finding out that you're
attracted to someone they also like
you could create the illusion that you
are not you never actually admit that
you aren't you just lead the
conversation so that it can be assumed
that you aren't
this is a powerful form of mind control
because it allows you to deny ever doing
anything wrong
since you have never admitted to
anything or lied about anything you can
easily say that it was the listener's
fault for not asking or for assuming
anything was implied
subliminal messages
when you use subliminal messages you are
sending messages without someone
actually knowing that you are doing so
these messages tend to slip past the
conscious mind and directly into the
subconscious the powerful thing about
subliminal messages is that you can be
telling someone one thing and yet having
them hear something entirely different
while this conscious mind digests
something they are willingly accepting
their subconscious mind may be hearing
something entirely different
because you have put them into a
receptive mode
they are more likely to react and
respond in the way that you want them to
and their subconscious mind is more
likely to accept the information as well
subliminal messaging is powerful because
it allows you to control the mind
without any indication that you're doing
so
you can speak directly through the
conscious mind and into the subconscious
mind thus planting information evidence
and knowledge into the subconscious that
encourages your listener to support your
position and act or think in the way
that you want them to
you are literally
programming their mind with your desired
messages
and they have no idea that you are doing
so
mind control is a very powerful strategy
that can enable you to have people
thinking in your favor
these individuals are going to
unknowingly be listening extremely
closely to your sentences and hanging on
your every word
while giving into anything you want
because of your masterful ability to
control their minds without them even
knowing it you will be able to have any
desired outcome
effortlessly
people often have a few different traits
which you can use to understand them
such things as their body language their
life situation and their emotions all of
these impact one another
in the following chapters we will break
down all of these aspects to help you
understand exactly what position you're
in
body language is a huge giveaway about
what's going on in a person's head
understand that in terms of
neuro-linguistic programming body
language is a language in and of itself
we're going to expand on this concept
just a bit so we can gain an
understanding of how we can read and
process other people's emotions
this is actually a very critical part of
neuro-linguistic programming and one of
the things that makes it such a
challenge
doing it properly is not like picking a
lock
there is no correct path for you to do
it right it's a very dynamic activity
which is heavily centered on your
ability to understand what the other
person is thinking in a very concrete
manner
understand that a person has many
physical tells
but that's not the be-all end-all of
what is going on in a person's mind
some people are so good at hiding their
emotions that you can't really tell
what's going on under the hood unless
you know them very well
often
people will have two emotions running in
parallel
these can be difficult to decipher but
generally they have the emotion at their
foreground
this is what they display themselves to
be feeling
and they have their emotion in the
background which is what they are
feeling under the hood
some people are worse than others when
it comes to hiding their emotions while
some people make no effort at all
there are times too when these emotions
may run in tandem and are exactly the
same
the truth is though that if you're
trying to convince somebody of something
you always have to consider the
possibility that people don't often feel
what they're projecting themselves to be
feeling
usually you have to consider what these
parallel emotions could be
we'll focus more on the underlying
emotions when we get to the chapter on
psychoanalysis however for now we just
need to focus primarily on reading
emotions on the surface
people convey a lot of their emotions
through their body language as well as
through their tone of voice and their
choice of words
if you pay attention to a person's eyes
you can read a lot into somebody's
foreground emotion
while hopefully you're emotionally
competent enough to read foreground
emotions relatively well note that some
of these can be difficult to break apart
from one another for example while the
difference between
annoyance and anger or slight in terms
of their physical display
they have far different emotional
connotations
annoyance is much shorter and less
severe though perhaps more immediately
snappy anger is more brooding and harder
to work your way out of
their tone of voice will also tell you a
lot
often when people aren't being
completely honest about the emotion
they're presenting
their voice will sound ever so slightly
off
being able to recognize this and using
context clues to figure out what's
really bothering them or going on in
their head is very important
sometimes their choice of words will
give you hints as well
pay attention and try to notice if their
sentences are structured differently
are they shorter
is their choice of words more serious
than usual
in essence pay attention to a person's
body language as it will tell you a lot
about what you need to know when it
comes to what a person is feeling at
least on the surface level
when you combine that with your analysis
of their underlying conditions you
actually get a very potent piece of
information that you can work with
nlp
neuro-linguistic programming
nlp involves the three most powerful
elements that contribute to the human
experience and they are
neurology
language
and programming
so
how can we use nlp to influence people
here are some answers to that
nlp techniques are in use both in
business and personal relationships to
influence people around you
nlp techniques are designed to help you
get your message across in the correct
way so that they are interpreted by
people to give you your desired outcomes
nlp techniques also focus on the choice
and appropriate use of language to help
you motivate people around you to get
something good done
nlp techniques are designed in such a
way that if used correctly they can help
you teach others how to become more
productive and efficient in their lives
which in turns helps you in your life as
well
nlp techniques are also designed for
salespeople so that they're able to
reach the subconscious level of the
buyer's mind in such a way that they
feel good and happy about buying the
product or service
the basic presumption of nlp is that
each of us is unique in the way we think
we interpret and the way we present
ourselves to the outside world
nlp says that if we know how we think
then we can be empowered to change the
way we think
extending the same logic outside of us
if we know how people think we can
empower ourselves and them to influence
changes in their thought processes
let us take an example
each of us has a unique way of
translating what we see around us into
thoughts
our preference could be to the use of
sight sound or touch or a unique
combination of all three
if our preferred sense is that of sight
then we easily convert the events of our
life into pictures and images in our
thoughts if our preferred sense is that
of touch we easily convert our
experiences into feelings
let's take this a bit further
suppose you had a preference for the
sense of sight
this preferred sense is actually very
evident in the way you interact with
others for example you will use phrases
like
see you later
or
i can see how this will turn out
etc
you will normally be the type of person
who decides that when something or
someone is out of sight then that person
or thing is
out of your mind too
so with a person whose sense preference
is that of touch
phrases like catch you later or
i'm getting a bad feeling from this etc
will be used
so by knowing these preferences and the
way they become evident through their
language and thought we can understand
people better and once we understand
their behavior we can more easily
influence the way they think
it is a natural thing to be fond of
those individuals who are like us in the
way they think and behave so by knowing
their preferred means of communication
we can use the same way to communicate
with them and therefore make it easy for
us to influence them
a classic example of nlp influencing
technique is to synchronize your
breathing with that of the other person
watch when the person breathes in and
you match your inhalation with that
when you match every breath of yours
with the other person's
you will find an invisible connection to
the individual giving you a great boost
in terms of influencing his or her
thoughts
thank you for listening